I forgot I was muted.
Hello, everyone.
It's just me right now.
It's just me.
I believe Duby is testing out her internet at the moment.
So it's just going to be me for now.
It's going to be me for now whenever she's ready.
Oh, my God.
Time went by so fast.
I was...
Oh, I was...
Oh, wow.
Sorry.
I went to bed at 5 in the morning.
What was I doing?
I have I have Lost stuff to do Literally so to be fair Um I
was playing video games I was To be fair okay okay I had
lost Stuff to do I also was Playing video games Minasan
Konichiwa Oh I'm sorry that That like That video was rent
free in my Head I've been like thinking about that the last
like 24 hours it's so good i don't know it's just it's the
japanese t-rex it's just i don't know there's just something
about it he's like my i just love it so much it's i don't
know there's something about it um anyway uh today we're
gonna be playing marbo vipers with dubay So yes, I will be
on my else account and I will try my best to see if I could
play tick So I because I want to be a dinosaur.
I want to play.
What's his name?
DD dinosaur devil dinosaur.
All right.
Okay, she's almost right.
You want to do it Have I
think we're going to do fogies.
I'm pretty sure I'm not sure because like if we're both
there it does take we gotta do that set i do a setup for it
but i think we're going to use fogies anyway what was i
gonna say uh oh yeah anyway i have technically i have like
three game like two games that have to relearn so i've been
hard grinding i know i haven't been hard grinding in apex
but i've been trying to relearn apex for those who didn't
hear i'll be in an apex tournament next week.
I'll be in an Apex tournament next week.
And I don't remember.
I don't know what's meta.
And I don't know what gun is meta.
Or anything.
So I've been trying to practice Apex for the tournament.
Oh, okay.
Hey, nobody's calling.
Wait, I don't hear you.
Oh, I had you at zero.
Oh, I have you muted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I forgot last time we had a collab.
Yeah, I forgot what the hell's like, why can't I hear it?
Okay, let me get you running on my screen.
Should we join our room for our...
Oh, yeah, I was like thinking about that.
I don't...
Yeah, I was thinking about that, too.
Okay, we gotta set that up.
Do you want us to do it, or should I do the room?
Uh, can you do it?
Alright, yes, yeah, yeah, sure.
Let me hide myself.
pool wait i'm gonna do a little magic trick guys i'm gone
for a bit uh so i can remember how to set this up oh wait
time we're not on any time crunch oh wait okay we might have
a little problem we might have a for okay wait i gotta buy
give me a sec i need to buy vtube studio on my other oh no i
had to do that too i had oh wait no i did buy it okay okay i
did buy it i just need to buy buy v i might have to buy do i
need to buy vbruger too okay let me buy v bruger oh no you
had to buy everything again buy everything i was like oh i'm
so smart i used to start with about steam thing i was like
oh i'm so clever and i was like oh apparently there is a way
to do it like to launch it without steam but it's kind of i
think it's like complicated like you have to put oh no no
it's actually pretty easy it's like if you click on browse
local files um it has like it has start without steam on
there oh yeah that's how i did it but then but you can't do
collab rooms because it requires your steam friends you know
because i was like oh that makes sense yeah let me buy it
real quick all right we're doing a shopping stream yay
shopping stream steam store browsing Steam store, guys,
recommend me some games, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to remember my PayPal password.
What the fuck is it?
Have you played a new season yet, Duby?
Yeah, a little bit.
How would you think about it?
No, I am not.
No, I have not touched a new season at all.
Because, like...
You don't like the Dino?
Oh, I was, like, watching streams of it.
And it's like, you know how, like, he blasts stars at you
and you just can't see anything and then he has this giant
shield that also has stars too so if you're trapped in the
dome it's like where is everything it's just all it's really
annoying like the dome the dome blocks healing and stuff
yeah yeah like he grabs you my elo people don't shoot it
they're like what am i gonna do there's a giant circular
thing on top of me do i you want me to shoot it oh that's
crazy how dare you suggest a thing all right let me have you
haven't done placements yet oh but no i don't yeah but i've
done it on my main or my alt account i've been just watching
i i played quick play because i played quick play because i
was just like i you know what you crave you crave some
marble rivals but they're like oh i don't want to lose elo
yeah yeah like those moments all right
into my steam
if old oh I use my PayPal app what are your games have you
been playing also I'm glad your internet got fixed I was
watching your last stream oh no no it was really bad it was
like I was like oh wait is that a new waiting room or
thought she had let's see wait oh I tried playing CS um
because they released the new map it's not new but it's like
uh new for the engine i guess oh yeah i heard i saw about
that i saw that like where uh they were like we're bringing
it back we're bringing back the new map yeah it's nice it's
nice to play on it i haven't really been playing anything
else besides like shooter games you know like yes yes and
marble wait children oh shooter games i was like children
shooter games
You know what I think about, like, how when you asked me,
when we went to convention together, you're like, do we,
what games are you playing?
And I'm like, oh, SpongeBob Cookoff on the Switch.
Literally a baby game.
Oh, you gotta, you know, sometimes you just want to relax
and play SpongeBob Cookoff.
Yeah, it's actually not relaxing at all, though.
It's really intense.
And how did the kids feel?
Did you try, oh, did you try a new Fortnite update?
with work oh no it's so okay i've been trying to get people
to play yeah the new overwatch update is actually so fucking
fun it's because like they added the overwatch weapons also
to my sound guy i brought dubi up a little bit already uh
but uh basically uh the weapons are so fun and uh and also
like tracer now has the biggest ass in fortnite i see yeah
that's crazy They did like, you know how like it was Chun-Li
before?
But they did like a, they did studies, like the, the
researchers.
The side by side.
Yeah, the side by side comparison opacity lock.
And it was like, crazy.
They're like, they've done it.
They've dethroned Chun-Li.
They gotta bring people back in because I think some people
stopped like playing.
Yeah, yeah.
They knew.
They need something.
They knew what the people wanted.
And it was.
Tracer's ass, I guess.
Well, yeah, they know.
They know.
But the guns are really fun.
I haven't had so much fun with
the new Fortnite updates before until now.
Alright, let me see.
Okay, you gotta add my alt account, Steam.
Pretty...
Oh, okay.
Don't worry about...
The name is pretty weird, I know.
It's like...
Oh, one second chat.
Alright.
That's my Steam account name.
Wait, are you on Twitch or are you streaming on YouTube?
I'm on YouTube, yeah.
Okay, yeah, you mostly stream.
Sometimes you stream on Twitch, though, right?
Yeah, I do it for, like, sponsors and stuff.
Well, you know, there's, like, Twitch drops.
So, oh, you could turn on Marble Rivals Twitch drops right
now.
Oh, I think it's on.
Oh, it's on automatically.
Yeah, guys, there's Twitch drops right now for Marble
Rivals.
You can get cool new skins.
Yeah, and all you have to do is watch Doobie for, I think,
like, three to four hours.
Three hours.
That's how long this clock's going to be anyways.
I don't know.
That's true.
All right.
Wait, what am I doing?
Oh, yeah.
I did this night.
Oh, okay.
I tried.
They're like, you have no friends and you're seamless.
Where are you trying to do a collab room for it?
I'm just like, I'm going to have a friend soon.
No way.
All right, my name's Corey on this.
Hey, Corey.
Corey in the house.
Oh my god.
10 out of 10.
I've always wanted to stream the Corey in the house game.
Stream it?
Yeah, yeah, they have like the DS game for Corey in the
house.
It has like a 10 out of 10 on the one.
No, it does.
Wait, it used to.
Corey in the house.
Reviews.
Oh my god, we're on IG.
Yeah, best anime ever Corey in the house house.
All right, let's see.
I'm setting up the streaming room.
Um, it's on Western NA and this is gonna, this will be the
password.
Okay, oh, okay.
This might, okay, actually, I might.
Chad, don't look.
Wait, it might not be.
Uh, yeah, that is the password.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait, actually, let me...
Okay.
I forgot to click host.
I was like, wait a minute.
Alright, collab room should be up.
Okay.
Wait, how do I do this all the way out?
It's been a while, I know.
It's been a while.
Can I join you off steam?
Oh, here it is.
Okay, hold on.
I get it.
Professional VTubers, by the way.
We've been streaming for how long now?
And don't worry, we know what we're doing.
Oh, that's me every day.
I'll be like, professional streamer here.
Wait, is it possible for you to send me an invite?
Is that possible?
Is that what people do?
Because there's like a plus sign and then if you click on
it, you should be able to click me.
Yeah, yeah, I did.
I clicked you.
You should be there Wait, did I invite did I oh, okay, I
think I'm are you in oh you're in you're in I saw it join it
do but Doob's in Okay, we're figuring it out guys.
It's our first time collabing with each other It's our first
very ever first ever collab with anyone ever guys.
Please be patient.
Please be kind I think we did this the last time we played
Marvel rivals together I think we also spent like 20 minutes
setting Guys, please be gentle It's our first time ever
doing a collab with anyone ever before We've been solo
streamers Yeah, this is our first stream I just, this is my
debut stream Right now I'm, this is my debut Hello
everybody, my name is Jokey Bird I'm, I like to play Marvel
Rivals And my likes and dislikes are Marvel Rivals And my
dislikes are Marvel Rivals And Are you are you an elf?
Is that why you have pointy ears?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm like I'm I'm I'm I'm I have knife ears.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, use that.
Okay, I was like, why did I start lagging?
Hello, you're like right behind me All right, I am I all
right now I get to control the position.
All right, let's see I should appear any second now.
My god move me too.
Alright guys, I know the lack of immersion because I still
am not using, you know Sprout?
I keep forgetting to set up.
Yeah, I keep forgetting to set that up.
It makes it so simple.
I know, it's like everything won't be like seen, but I'm
like, I'll do that later.
And then later never happens.
Let's see.
One day.
It takes a minute.
Guys, you don't understand.
It takes so much work, guys.
much effort like you don't understand I just don't have that
time guys I'm too busy playing Marvel Rivals this is my
first stream please be nice you don't have it set up yet
yeah of course yeah yeah exactly it's my first stream that's
why we haven't set anything up we haven't said anything up
yet yes this is my first stream please be nice all right
we're kind of ready now I think I think so, too.
Are we?
Yeah.
I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
See, look at us.
We're so professional.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
So, we'll be able to play comp together, right?
Yeah, we should be.
You're diamond, too, right?
Yeah, I D-rank.
Oh.
I think it's fine.
It's such like a plan.
Yeah, exactly.
See, everything's fine.
That's good.
That makes it easier, you know?
The climb.
Don't worry.
It's either we go up or we go down.
We're gonna go up.
We're going up.
We're always gonna go up in the end if we're gonna go up in
the end All right, do we up a little bit more?
I'll help you a little bit more All right, let me write this
down.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Let me write this down The only sad thing is I don't have my
twerking my twerking venom which makes me sad I definitely
win in our games.
Can you please please?
Yeah, can you please play venom and then twerk for me?
please just for old times sake i'm ready hopefully there's a
game audio okay i'm probably ready to wait maybe let me go
into practice range really quick all right hold on all right
i know why i'll go in there i'm going practice too also but
but if you don't play venom do not throw our games you can
be venom on the enemy team throw it but i don't encourage
throwing by the way just if you don't play venom and you're
on our team do not do not play venom please play your main
try your best try your best yes as long as you try your best
i won't report you all right chat can you hear me i think my
game is fine i don't I always, like, write down when I do,
like, when I do games, I play the most.
I always write down what the audio is that I put in.
So diligent.
So I'd never forget.
Yeah, if I won't install the one program.
Yeah, if I won't install the one.
That, okay, that's just extra steps, okay?
That's, I actually do have the program installed.
I just, I'm just lazy and setting it up on OBS.
Oh, okay.
I think that's even worse.
I actually have it installed.
just don't have it on for here where are you in all right oh
there you are wait is this is choo-choo your main or yeah
this is my main account okay I have all my spicy skins on
here oh you mean the blocky iron man I will you got her oh
my god you actually oh my god okay well this was just part
of the i didn't get this one on purpose no yeah yeah it
wasn't for hell i wanted the lunar skin sure what what you
could have showed me the lunar skin but you went straight to
the hell i don't have it yet i haven't unlocked it i mean
you have crazy skins on your account well not the ones where
i have crazy skins on my Overwatch account.
But like these skins, you have to pay real money.
So I was just like, no.
Instead, I use real money to buy Overwatch skins.
That's fair.
Yeah, it's... Wait, what?
We use real money in there, but not in this one?
Okay, I told myself I would never spend money in Overwatch
because I had a problem when Overwatch 1 first came out,
which was... You know, it's 10 years ago.
They had... 10 year anniversary anniversary started wait
what yeah the 10-year anniversary started two days ago yeah
it's been dubious in 10 years dubious in 10 years yeah so um
i told myself i would never spend real money on overwatch
but uh because it's like i had a real problem in overwatch
one where i would buy like I've actually bought around at
least a hundred loot boxes at one point.
I had a real problem.
Like, it was really, it was really bad.
You can get it for free back then, no?
You can, but also, like, I really, I think I was like, I
really wanted to have, like, some particular skins.
So I was like, I cannot wait to grind.
I have to, I have to get the skins.
So I need it.
I need it now.
Yeah, I was like, I need this.
I need, I don't have these skins.
I can never play.
But you bought the new bunny skin?
The new bunny girl.
I did.
Okay, so at first, I was really strong with it.
Like when Overwatch 2 came out, and like when I came back to
Overwatch for a bit, when Overwatch 2 came out, I never
bought any skins.
And I was like, I'm stronger than this.
I am strong.
And then it started off really slow.
So they released a near collab in Overwatch.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So the thing is, when they released a San Diego collab, I
didn't give in.
I was strong because I loved Sonamoro and Karomi And I was
like, I won't do this.
I will never buy these skins.
Like, I am strong.
And then they released the near collab.
And the Kiriko 2B skin was so pretty.
It was like...
That's how they get you.
I know.
I was just like, that's how they got me.
Because I was like, well, I have to play Kiriko.
And I don't want to look.
I only had two skins on Kiriko, by the way, before all of
this.
I only had two skins on Kiriko from...
Wait, so you play that game more than this?
It's like 50-50 now.
I'm tired of triple support on Rivals.
Oh, yeah.
Triple support is like really boring for me because nothing
dies.
So that's why I haven't been playing as much.
So I've been playing Overwatch a little bit more.
But then, and then I haven't bought any skins after 2b near.
And then the bunny, the bunny girls dropped.
I couldn't.
The trailer.
No, did you see the trailer though?
Did you see the...
It can happen to anyone.
Like... Okay.
come on like did I see I bought something in Overwatch yeah
yeah I got um for the Hello Kitty collab oh yeah there's
like a Lucio line it's like okay okay okay yeah that's so
cute I think I have that too I think wait actually did I
actually buy it whoops oh no wait I'm on the free I'm on the
free version no I forgot no I thought I had to buy I thought
I bought it but I'm actually on the free version of the i
forgot to buy the collab you know how the collab room also
yeah buy it for the collab room like a five minute limit
isn't there yeah free trial yeah i use trial dokey does
anyone have another email account can use to extend my free
trial let me install the collab dlc all right i'm installing
i need to put in more tokens i need more tokens guys does
anyone have more tokens i'm gonna save this position too so
i don't have to fucking redo it move me record all right all
right i gotta close my do i have to close this to activate
it important okay wait do i have it now let's see let me see
i don't know about it just in case um all right guys don't
worry i also bought the ramatra janitor skin too oh oh did
you see that one okay wait it's it's so funny it's because
like you're gonna show it to me yeah i'll show it to you
it's really funny it's because like he has this emote where
you can use where you know like those emails where you can
move and stuff while in game so he has All right, but this
is also one reason why I bought it is because he leaves
puddles while he's walking and I thought that was so funny I
was like, oh my god He leaves water.
Okay.
Ramatra clean emote
So he has an emote where he's cleaning and you can use it in
the middle of a fight I don't I saw a tweet of someone like
just walking past like in the middle of a big-ass fight and
he just like he's just cleaning in the background oh yeah I
like that I know I had oh my god I had to I had to get it
guys first time guys I'm sorry I'm a first time streamer I
forgot to buy the trial the collab DLC alright
okay I've done it again alright you can come back in it's
the same password and everything alright one moment Guys,
this is my first stream.
Guys, the best part is about watching the journey of a new
streamer and how she gets better at being a streamer, guys.
Yeah.
You can watch my journey.
It starts today.
Join me on my journey.
I'm just a new streamer.
There it goes.
I think it should...
I hope one day I'll have at least a 10-viewer average.
That's my goal.
10 viewers.
Yeah, 10 viewers.
Do you know how many people are in 10?
How many people can fit in a room of 10?
It's a lot of people.
I hope one day I get that.
There's my dog.
Hey, no.
No.
Alright.
Let me know when you're in.
Wait, you are?
Where are you?
I think it just takes a while.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
Yeah, I see that.
It says that you're about to join.
Alright, I need to go feed my dog.
I'll be right back.
Where's my blush?
Wait, you guys can't see this part?
I'm back.
You're like...
You're still like not here on my screen.
I'm just gonna wait until you...
Up here.
It's just me.
By myself.
Am I on your other side?
Yeah.
Yeah, fuck.
I think it's my internet maybe.
Oh, it could be.
Are you like lagging on stream?
On your end?
I think so.
Maybe.
Haha!
Am I lagging on Discord?
No, you're not.
You're pretty clearly fine.
Our enemies are here.
Is that my lagging?
Oh, wait, oh, you're here!
And I scared.
No, no, this is what I see.
I feel like by the club.
Well, I'm trying to map your head, you guys.
Wait, wait, this is...
Oh, look, look, look at the screenshot I sent you.
Oh, my head's cut off.
By the club.
yeah i think that's good oh i just realized i forgot one
more thing i gotta turn my aim bot on oh me too okay yeah i
mean botting turning on my wands turning on my configs
all right we should be good now we're good guys now we're
good oh my god i think god do we i think we can become like
real streamers i think i think we have potential Do you
believe in us?
Do you believe in us?
Newly debuted VTubers, by the way.
First time.
Cannot wait.
Alright, thank you.
We're good.
We're good for real this time.
For real, for real.
For real.
I'm gonna try and pick Donald.
Devil Dinosaur.
Are you gonna play for the first time in comp?
Or you play him quick play.
I was in the early axis for devil dinosaur He's so oh my god
like you need like all supports pumping so much heals on him
just to do anything Oh, yeah, yeah, he dies so fast.
Yeah, it's like that's why I'm like so scared about like
lower elo or lower elo Playing with devil dinosaur because
I'm like well my support healed me Like am I gonna survive.
Oh, okay.
I believe I believe I believe in the the doobie gambit All
right, cue us up doobie Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready
Oh my god, that was a fast kill I took one sip of water and
we're in
Hmm Also, oh, let me push you a tiny bit higher On discord
and we should be good
I did turn up my mic volumes.
Hopefully it sounds a little bit louder because my mic has
been really quiet.
Oh yeah, because you recently you changed setups, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I updated my mic.
I'm going to build a new PC.
I actually have to build a new PC.
Oh my god.
I'm going to.
I have it.
No, no, it's still here.
I'm still using it.
I just want to update it because it's...
Oh.
It's...
It's alright.
It actually lags when I play Marvel Rivals on it.
I think it's just the optimization.
Marvel Rivals optimization has never been that great.
And they recently got rid of Confix to fix optimization.
Because they wanted to I don't know if you saw that.
They wanted to counter the mods.
Because people were...
They didn't like people modding the game.
And stuff.
Yeah.
I saw that.
Mario Rivals has some fucking crazy ass mods.
Have you seen some of them?
Yes.
I saw it.
one where some guy was like, look at this amazing play I did
on Invisible Woman.
And it was like, like, it was like, inflated Invisible
Woman.
And people were like, I've seen the big widow, the big
school girl.
And we were like, we have, there's a, please address the
elephant in the room.
There's a lot of skin mods where they give them like banana
hammocks instead.
Oh, yeah.
all right I'm here to chomp guys don't worry if we lose
don't we're up down is up eventually if we play enough games
we'll go up if we lose this I'm de-ranking the plot that
means the games will get easier do we just think okay get
easier games to climb higher true yeah have you seen that
video It's been my vocal stim.
I want to go there.
I didn't even realize that...
Wait, you want to go... Wait, is it a place?
Yeah, it's in... Wait, are we talking about the same clip?
The dinosaur clip?
I've seen like the person who does those videos where they
like do a bunch of them where they just have some person on
the street filmed them eating like oniguri and they're like
please film me oh no okay it's a different video okay so
there's like this museum in japan where it's a giant t-rex
and then he's like like an animatronic and then suddenly
he's like yeah it's so good i'll send you after this all
right oh my god wait he's also donald what do i do oh yeah i
also have a Oh shit!
Okay, he has, um, I exploded.
He dragged me into the mines.
He's so smart.
Alright, he might be a better Dino than me.
Dude, that's evil.
I saw a clip of that where they grab like the other tank and
then they coordinate with Penny mines.
That's great!
I didn't even realize that was a combo!
No wonder he's on Penny!
Oh my god, he's gonna try and do that again.
He's trying, oh my god, I'm taking so much damage.
He wants to grab me guys.
What do I do?
I got him!
Get him!
Oh shit!
Someone help me!
It's cuz the head is- your head is so big!
It's okay.
Mina-san, Konnichiwa!
You talk in voice chat in this game, right?
Not, barely.
No?
What?
I thought I seen you talking in voice chat.
I do when it's like funny You know I got him I'm throwing
him into the portal That's right That's right He's so stuck
Okay but I'm stuck too Oh no He got me I think I think
they're a dino I think that dino might be a better You're
Donald and me.
Yeah, it's...
It might be...
They have more time.
That's true.
It's not my fault.
It's my team's fault.
I'm creating space.
I'm literally creating space.
Like, I am a space creator.
I think that's the problem.
Yeah, yeah, it's so true.
It's always the DPS.
Here you go!
I brought him back again!
How many times do I have to bring him back to us?
Oh, yeah.
I don't like wasting my...
I'm just gonna ult you with the idea.
Okay, those mines go hard.
Those mines go with your...
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh wait, dice!
They're blaming the Namor!
It's not me!
It's never me!
I'm just a dinosaur.
I know if I have like zero kills, like most of our team.
Yeah, yeah.
So it's not me guys.
It can't be me Wait, what the fuck?
Oh shit Yeah, care about the mines I'm I'm trying Oh,
there's the mines though Alright It's okay It's no longer
okay Everybody's dead
It's not...
Hey, our GPS.
Okay, we have Hella.
Okay, our Hella's doing stuff.
Our Hella's doing stuff.
Look, in the end, we did our...
It's okay.
It's warm up.
It's a warm up game.
Yeah, true.
It's warm up.
No, no, it's okay.
This is our warm up.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh no, not again.
Oh my god, he grabbed me while I was trying to get out grab.
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
We have a strange on point.
It's okay, the strange can kill 20.
I will say.
One of them has zero kills.
It's not also me.
Can we need you to lock it on Groot?
Unless he's banned.
Alright, alright.
No, no, I can make it work, I swear.
He's banned.
Oh, he is banned.
Alright.
Let's see.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We have Penny now.
I can grab him into the Penny mines and do what he did for
me.
True.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
Can't him still.
all right here we go it's not cope guys it's not cope I
swear it'll work it's called belief yeah why do I have to
what we have to okay fine fine I'm a good I'm a team player
you know even though I'm on an else account I will just for
it oh I'm getting no value sure okay I literally I know I
chomped did not see me choke Yum.
Wait, do you know if Punisher's man, we could have ran
Punisher.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, my God, I could have ran Emma.
Emma.
I've been practicing Punisher.
We could combo next game.
Oh, my God.
We could.
We could do that.
That's what we were missing.
The Punisher Dino duo.
Yeah.
Honestly.
I love how it's like an action figure, like playing on a
dinosaur complete.
You know what?
I know what we were missed.
I should play to Emma, though.
Emma's really good against Dino.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
And that's like the hard counter.
She grabs him, right?
Yeah.
Like, how does she fit her?
Hand around his throat.
Oh my god, she has the grip, you know?
That's the grip.
Don't worry.
See?
We got this.
Don't worry.
I'm gripping.
Wait, what are you gripping?
I'm gripping my rocks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What are they gonna do, huh?
I'm tanking.
I'm doing my job.
That's fucking right.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god!
I'm so healthy!
What?!
How did I die?
I literally went backwards!
Look, that's not my fault.
I backed up.
We're holding the line.
All right, hold the line.
Hold the line.
I'm waiting for you.
Don't worry, I'm almost there.
I will do the tank job again.
Oh my god, they had two support ults already?
I guess because of the dino.
I almost have mine.
I'm pretty sure it's because of the dino.
Don't worry.
I've shielded myself.
Oh, it's because he was like farming them?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, he does do like less heals.
I think it's over.
I think it might be over.
I'm...
It's not our fault, though.
Yeah.
It's not our fault.
We, it's honestly, I created so much space.
It's not my fault my team didn't utilize the space created.
Yeah, yeah, it was actually our DPS.
I know.
One of them was good.
Yeah, one of them was good.
The other one.
The other one was...
Oh, wait.
they put the other one.
Wait, this guy was like playing Mystery Heroes.
He didn't even know what to play.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
See, you're not plat yet.
Dude, we still... It's fine.
Oh.
Yeah, we just don't have a chance.
Alright, we're gonna bring it back.
We're locking in.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm locked in for real now.
This time.
I gave an upboat to the only good teammate.
Yep.
That's me.
I didn't give any upboats.
Where's my updude?
I'm just so used to not Not sending updudes They gotta Work
for it Yeah earn my My updudes Alright Yeah okay Alright
this time This time it'll work Trust I watched Marvel Rivals
Ignite Today I watched the pros do it It's not that hard I'm
pretty sure Did you get your exclusive twitch drops Oh my
god The Marvel Rivals Ignite Yeah Yeah Oh my god If you did
it you can get it right now On Doobie's Shadow Oh really
wait No way No way For free Yeah Oh yeah, the video.
Let me send it to you.
It's a really good video.
It's been my vocal stim.
That's what each of you words.
Minasan, konichiwa.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know.
There's something about it.
It just hits all the right spots for me.
And then I get it.
I got to fix my monitor really quick to see it.
Great chat.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Yay.
I hope they give a twerking up for Devil Dinosaur.
That wouldn't even, I don't think it would even work.
Indeed, they did for Jeff though.
Did not see the Jeff twerks?
The red heroes could make all the difference.
They did for Jeff.
Oh my God, they banned them.
My own team banned Devil Dinosaur.
No!
That was good.
Our team bandit.
Our own team.
They don't believe in us.
We even had the team up!
Why don't they trust us?
Fine.
This is the only other tank I know how to play.
They hate me.
They just hate dealing with a Dino as well.
Maybe they...
Yeah, but...
Does your account have like history?
No.
Maybe they check.
It's private.
Unless they do like...
can bypass the privacy i think that's crazy like really yeah
there's a yeah but it's a paid subscription apparently
people have been using like this program just to like um
just a bad one tricks all right or are you gonna play
oh we're exciting to be good bro i'm going i'm going
it's okay i'm here i'm here we're here oh nevermind i just
mixed randomly but i got distracted with your dinosaur video
i'm sorry it's a good video it's a good video if you're
distracted by any video it should be that it was a good
video oh my god wait where's my oh my uh where's my support
you everybody like backed up guys oh i'm solo tanking okay
i'm not solo tanking on emma
wait should i tank i can tank you want to yeah it won't yeah
whichever one works with man is this enough healing that's a
good question i actually don't know I'm heading over!
No!
No fight!
Exiled.
Oh, tank pool.
Okay, yeah, that's good.
I think I can play.
I can go back to Emma.
Don't worry.
Look at that.
All right.
I believe in us.
It should be fine.
Oh!
I think I've ever died to her alt like that before.
oh my god there is so many things going on my screen
look it's not our fault we're creating space uh yeah yeah
yeah we're literally creating space what can we do i think
it might actually be because no no no no no stay alive right
it's not our fault we're creating space thing that tanks are
supposed to do holy shit wait do we have any wait we don't
have a support okay we just got her support this is rough
this is a little rough this is a little rough but no it's
okay it's okay we're warming up all right we go we leave we
leave we leave do you have time I have time oh fuck I don't
have time I'm backing up I don't know you'll live do me I
won't oh my god oh I I did that to save you and oh please
let them look at me okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
that's good that's good she she looked at me i have all i
have all i do have a wait what the fuck did he else is i
don't i don't even know where that was yeah i'm like where
okay i got the white fox i got the white fox i got Angela
this furry this big this goddamn furry get out of here oh
god oh god okay Just keep jumping!
I don't know how to do this.
Wait, you don't know how it was?
No, no, no, like, I'm good, I'm good.
Oh my god.
It's okay, it's not us.
We're making space!
We're literally making space!
It's not us!
We're making space!
It's not...
I like, uh, how do you talk and play this game at the same
time?
There's so much shit happening.
There's so much.
I know.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, I missed.
Oh god.
Please.
I'm trying my, where's my, oh my god, please Luna.
I'm, don't shoot at you, Starlord.
Shoot at me.
Good at you.
No, I, Luna didn't heal me while I was on the car.
Like, please!
We're not beating, right?
We're not, we're not.
We're creating space.
Space has been created.
I'm literally doing everything I can to create space.
Oh, please.
Tell me if there are stuff going...
My support is gonna... Oh, my support.
I stalled What was that?
Someone in voice chat is losing their mind
It's okay
Look see?
See?
She died with walls!
Just remember!
This person died with walls!
So it's not us!
Okay, we're bringing it back!
Yeah, yeah, we're bringing it back.
We're bringing it back.
I didn't die with Walt.
Do you want to stay over here because Angela's back here?
Okay.
Where is there's a Starlord, too?
Where did he go?
He's right here.
Oh, break that break that break that break that break that.
Oh, there you go.
Oh my god.
Is one?
Who is?
All right.
Okay, we got a lot of time off the call.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we got a lot of time.
We can push this.
Oh, we're triple tank.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
We can do this.
Might be about to die.
Oh my god, I'm so low.
I can't see, there's so many things out running or jumping
around.
I hate this, good point.
There's so many things jumping around on my screen.
It really is like that one image of the cartoon, or like
that one video, the cartoon Smoke Cloud and the...
a top-notch team to win this one.
Alright.
All I'm saying, she died with vault, so it's not us.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
She died with vault, guys.
They want you to play Magneto.
Yeah, I hear it.
Oh, wait, they don't, they want to play.
Oh, wait, they, all right.
I guess we'll play support.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
I guess we're on support now.
You want, which one you want to play?
I mean, we need a hits good note.
All right.
I'll play whatever you want.
I'll counter, I'll cop them, whatever you want to.
You're my rank.
You're my ELO symbol.
Okay.
I'll do Luna.
Guys, just so.
Oh, yeah.
There's a team up, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember, guys.
Remember.
She died with all.
Not us, though.
Not us.
We didn't.
He's not available.
He created space.
Purple DPS.
This is good, right?
Yeah, this is good.
This should be good.
Oh, everybody's on Lord Icon, stuff for us.
Oh.
Well, I didn't really play this lady too much, so I'm
getting there.
Yeah, we're almost there.
Like, hello.
Don't worry, we're so, we're so healthy.
See, look at that.
I hit somebody.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, see?
Nothing to worry about.
What the fuck is Adam doing?
This is actually going pretty well, yeah.
Yeah, see?
Like, what are you doing, Angela?
Get out of here!
What are you doing, Adam?
Oh, he's flying away.
He's like up on high ground.
He's a coward.
Yeah, fight us!
That's looking right.
You know what?
Oh, shit.
Maybe not.
Oh, she blocked it.
I could have actually killed her.
But I killed her.
But why did she, why did he, like, rip her closer?
What?
Oh, the...
The Spider-Man, like, sent the Hulk to us.
Oh, that's a little awkward.
Oh, I'm at 95.
That's unlucky.
What did that guy say?
I have no idea.
Hulk Tula?
All right, I'll go first.
Okay.
All right, and he is though.
Thank you.
All right.
You should have Rez as well.
You got a bubble for you.
You're frozen.
All right, I got one.
you are the dps yeah i am oh shit they're born again don't
worry we don't need it yet okay we'll okay we're gonna need
it here oh my god why did i spider-man walk so far away oh
you might need all of this when i'm done i'm done i'm done
oh where are people i'm like so confused
many things on my screen right now yeah i'm gonna kill you i
see you little guy here you go goodbye i guess i'm the dps
now kill that luna look at me look at me exactly i should
have healed them i got two coffee with being dps i did not
heal our spider-man this guy on our team easy easy yeah
that's a spider-man yeah i didn't heal him i was like i'm
not gonna heal you i'm in a dps and i did and i did it was a
good trade it was exactly the trade was worth it equivalent
exchange my life is worth more than the spider-man that's
all i'm gonna say no for real oh okay
I did so much healing there.
It's not my fault.
We're the team of magic.
Oh, that rocket was so low.
Really?
I'm gonna put it on myself, actually.
Oh, shit.
Okay, never mind.
I guess I'll kill him.
Bro, kill one of them!
Oh, what is it?
What the?
Stupid?
He like tried to...
Oh yeah, I'm gonna tap card, you can heal them.
Wait, there's a...
Oh my god, you stupid?
Don't do that again?
Okay, I'll...
You saw that, yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh shit, I wasn't sure with him.
What's that?
That's weird.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
Oh no, I couldn't save him.
I am ready to play on a show.
I mean, you could ult this here.
I mean.
What do you mean right now?
Oh yeah, no, you can ult it again.
It's fine.
There we go.
Yeah!
Firepower!
Oh my god, he's so low though.
Okay, yeah, we win this.
Yeah, I put all my damage on them.
See, easy.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
See, I was making it easier for them when I play tank, you
know?
They want to embarrass them.
on support.
Going easy on them.
I didn't want to embarrass them.
Okay, now we got embarrassed, these people are putting me on
support.
Uh...
They need to try you with that.
Alright.
Come on, get that Namor!
Get that Envis!
Oh my god, that Envis actually won though.
Oh!
That's bad.
Oh, I got you.
Oh!
Thank you, never mind!
Never mind!
Holy shit, what's wrong with you?
Okay.
See, now it looks embarrassing.
What?
Oh!
That is not huge, unfortunately.
We keep fighting this.
There's really a name or...
Oh no!
Why?
I just got here.
I know!
I was like, oh no!
He really hates you!
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, they do an anti.
Okay, we have one more fight.
Oh, shoot.
Last fight.
Get that vehicle moving again!
I know, they really... you literally just got back from the
fight and they weld you.
Yeah, I'm just...
Oh, that's a window.
Oh, he's trying to...
Trying to stop the portal.
Bro, we didn't even portal, bro.
No, he didn't just walk out.
He's just like, I did it, guys.
I stopped the portal.
He didn't even stop anything.
We're just gonna casually walk over.
Oh, I should not miss that.
Are we in triple here?
Yeah, I was just looking at that.
Why?
Oh, wait.
Wait, what happened to her strange?
Um, I don't know.
Not me.
Wasn't my fault.
I did my job.
I will say.
The next one we got it.
Yeah, yeah, the next one.
Yeah, yeah.
Next game.
I can't wait to rank up.
It's going to be so exciting.
Oh my, I know, right?
It's going to be so cool when it happens.
Look at that.
That's so cute.
I did my job.
Look, I created space and I healed.
Did I heal a lot?
I don't even know.
I think so.
I didn't even see it.
Alright, let's see.
Oh yeah, we did a lot of healing.
Eh.
Don't worry.
This next one.
Where's tank dokey?
They kicked us off a tank, okay?
we were we evolved okay yeah we we did really good like we
were on tank on attack we would have probably got that
honestly 100 we would have done so much yeah that's on them
that's not they didn't want the win we were you were gonna
hand in their win on a silver platter and they didn't want
it yeah yeah like we did so well on attack on tank too.
Maybe this game we can do the... Oh, that's true.
We can.
Maybe this time.
What you think you want to be today?
Alright.
They're gonna be so impressed with our combo.
This is where we're gonna win.
This is it.
I'll play Punisher, but I'll probably switch off it.
Okay, we have a cloak.
Yeah, we have a cloak player.
Yeah, it's fine.
That's okay.
Alright, solo tank.
Donald, that's okay too.
That's alright.
oh we're this is defense isn't it is it dino is good on any
i think so dino is good on any that's my motto i was like
see my mic we didn't ban anything oh shit okay i was looking
away i don't even know what to ban in this helo like what
people mostly ban like moon night
because it's the new season there's like new bands so i
don't even know what the new bands are uh-huh i don't know i
don't really need that yeah i don't know either i am what
are the new bands yeah what are the new bands chat at chat
chat go to the marble rivals with yeah chat open up some
marble rival marble rivals ignite and tell us what are they
banning chat
i don't think I know Dino's been constantly banned, but only
because, like, Dino and the high Elo is, like, so broken.
Because they actually know what they're doing.
Uh-huh.
That's scary.
Oh, they said Daredevil, Phoenix, Gambit.
Oh, shit.
We did not ban Gambit, Luke.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
We didn't ban Gambit.
All right.
We're gonna solo tank Dino.
Let's run it.
Don't worry.
You can only switch Gambit, and then you'll carry.
That's so true.
Wait, but there...
Our team already has...
a gambit though yeah we got this guys i believe
do you uh should i set up on point as punisher or should i
just sit on you here here oh wait i think oh wait there you
go come on come on get over here all right i'm solo tanking
so they're gonna shoot at you i love how punisher has this
like you sitting sideways like a Oh yeah.
Like a horse shows at the circus.
He does little tricks.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Did you see the...
Oh, you see the emote of Dino sitting on top of Jeff?
Because he has the riding.
No, I haven't.
I need to show his screen.
It's so good.
All right.
I'll do like this jiggle peek.
Because I don't like it.
So you can poke them if you want.
Tokey source wrecks.
Minasai.
that's not fair why do they have two tanks this is not fair
that's not fair why are they playing the game properly yeah
excuse me um i'm solo tanking
oh my god you're off get out of there oh my god you're not
on me anymore what do i do
i don't know if we should do it all the time.
I came back!
Grab him!
Oh, never mind.
He's gone.
You should die here.
What the fuck?
I got him!
We got him!
See?
See, this is it.
This is the dream duel.
Don a Punisher.
We figured it out.
See, they're so scared.
You don't know.
Here.
Get on my back.
Get on me.
There you go.
Come on, got him!
Shoot him!
It's fine.
He's so low!
But I got him!
I did it!
There you go!
You shoot him as much as you want!
Oh, I fucked up.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
No!
Where's my...
Um, excuse me.
Where's my heal?
Wait, we don't even have...
Oh, yet?
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I'm coming back.
we got it we got it yeah yeah yeah dino is coming back roar
look at you look at us go see you guys oh my god big boy is
coming big boy is almost here i have all two nice all right
that all is scary yeah yeah you want to get on i'm right
here i think some of them are going into that room oh shit
oh shit i'm He's backing out.
I can ult this.
Fuck it!
RAR!
Oh my god, they all did.
Alright, goodbye.
I mean, that's fine.
They all did.
It's a good exchange, good exchange.
They don't have...
They don't have a support ult now.
I grabbed him!
Oh, nice!
I'm reloading!
Shoot, it always happens when I'm...
Oh my god, that was...
You should have seen the bubbles.
That was actually crazy.
I grabbed him!
Oh shit, I got slept.
I'm turning around for the punishment.
Nice.
I don't have bubbles, so good luck everybody.
But I can't grab him though.
Yeah!
I shot him in your mouth.
Oh hey there, Phoenix, I'm coming over.
Oh shit, you're so lucky.
I'm here there alone, sorry.
I went back to Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Me too.
I went back for healers too.
Look at that.
I'm gonna chomp you.
Got you!
Chomp!
Oh!
Oh, let's hope we don't have us.
Oh, no!
No supports!
Oh, you're so close!
Someone quick!
Swap the strange I have Donald Oh, should I okay, okay.
I can I can yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm too
slow.
It's okay We're getting over.
Oh, it's too late.
It's all right.
I Wanted to stay.
It's fine.
It's okay I guess I'll stay up.
Thanks for now.
No, you were doing so good It was working
Oh my god.
Um, how do I play straight?
Um...
Okay, can I go back to Punisher?
Can you go back to Punisher?
Okay.
It worked, remember?
It worked.
Yeah, we got out of time.
Get on me.
Oh, okay.
Come on, devil.
There we go.
Watch this.
Yeah!
Oh, he's on thing now because he doesn't want to get
grabbed, pussy.
Yeah, I know you don't want to get grabbed.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my onions.
Oh, I got slept.
That's fine.
Oh, I died.
They hate you.
They hate.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Holy shit.
These are some generational plays I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm doing, but it's generational.
I did it.
Nice hold.
Nice.
I don't know what I did, but it was generational.
Somehow.
Oh, I did.
I just started chomping.
Oh, they're portaling.
They're portaling.
Oh, I'm dead.
I should have gone back to you guys.
Wait, where's my support?
Where's my support?
Oh,
I could not touch.
I didn't realize the thing was just all on our back of the
eye.
Man.
Holy shit.
Our Spider-Man friggin sucks.
Yeah, I know, right?
Team Spider-Man diff right there.
Yes, we don't have Spider-Man.
Yes, Spider-Man diff.
Still, still.
Your Spider-Man was better.
No need to have a Spider-Man.
Oh my god.
Or Luna.
I even made a circle for him too.
I mean, we could...
I mean, I'm trying to go up right now.
It's better.
We can wait.
Okay, there we go.
I didn't eat the old my best it's fine it's fine he's dead
oh we didn't eat that old though like if anything we did not
need that wait we used all our wait no all our ults are gone
why did we use the why do we use the gambit okay I don't
know okay it was so winnable okay the gambit was something
we definitely didn't need I think because it's the Gambit
Punisher combo is really good, so maybe they want a death.
Yeah, but it was already win.
We already won it.
Oh, he's right behind me.
Yeah, he is.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
All right, after this.
Dino Lizard!
Okay.
Never mind.
It's no longer Dino Lizard.
Look, I've popped...
It's okay.
We popped two support outs for that.
up for we have luna up for this okay not us throwing into
this yeah exactly how could it be us i'm doing so much i'm
creating space okay i hope i hope i get okay there you go
nice she's bright he's bright as a star
Here we go.
Look at that!
We can push it all the way.
This is fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, we can...
This is winnable.
This is so winnable.
The current score is 0 to 2.
It's okay.
Yeah, we're...
Human Torch is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're moving which side you're on?
I created space.
You'll need a top-notch team to win.
You're doing really good at Soul Tank.
Yeah, like, look at that.
Look at that.
Look at me.
I'm so cute.
Yeah, I think my problem might be that I don't have the
Punisher Beach skin.
That is so true.
It doesn't look like you're having a good time, you know?
Yeah.
My bullets are missing, too, because...
Yeah, yeah, because your clothes are weighing you down.
Yeah.
You need to take it off so your arms will be more free to
control your recoil, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's recoil control.
Oh my god, we actually have a double tank.
Yeah, it's all physics-y.
They're just so heavy.
You look like you belong in high school.
Hello.
You're on my back.
Okay.
Oh, why don't you get up?
Do it.
I did it.
Wait, if you melee while I'm on your back, does it...
No, it doesn't.
Well, my melee is my...
Oh, my melee is my attack.
That's my ammo.
My bite is my ammo.
Is it like your tail?
Oh, yeah, my melee is my tail.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Yeah, you have to, like, face them.
Yeah, your melee is crazy.
Somebody did that to me in a game, and it felt like DM.
Oh, oh, wait, that kicks you off.
Yeah.
Wait, he's on.
That's it.
I got you, strange.
Wait, he got me.
Wait, that's...
That fucking ramp got you again!
Where you go?
What the fuck?
Oh, he flew.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no!
It's okay.
We still have our other tank.
Oh, never mind.
Our Johnny's dead.
Wait, where is our other tank?
Our venom is playing backline.
Why is her venom in the backline?
Where are you?
Oh, no.
He's on...
He's running our strat!
Yeah, they stole our...
They knew it was so good.
Wait, he actually is running our strat!
It's fuckers!
It is kind of OP though.
It is pretty good.
It's a lot of damage, I won.
No!
Oh shit.
Get out of there!
I'm out of here.
What the fuck?
You try to grab me, but it didn't work.
Grabbed me behind you, too.
Oh my god.
I'm backing out a little bit.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
I shielded a bit.
That's the best I can do.
Oh my god.
He was right behind me.
They couldn't heal.
Why do we?
Why do we support him?
We had a Luno.
Oh, no, wait, I don't think we did.
We still have it.
No, she had it.
Oh, they support Alton?
No.
Oh, why didn't we?
Yeah, why didn't we support Alton?
What the fuck?
Wait, our other tank went support.
What the fuck is going on, bro?
Man, we had a pick, too.
Oh, we got a pick.
Oh, my God.
No.
That's it.
Oh, okay, we got it.
Bye.
where am i where is he i was just like i just kept chomping
i couldn't even tell where i went oh no yeah i'm always i'm
putting back
oh man there's a standing up there oh my god wait what did
he portal oh the portal in the air again no soon we'll have
to portal do we hold it though uh i mean we can not portal
okay the time entanglement is all right let's see if i
remember how to do this look over there i'm gonna get portal
on point
oh my god where am i where
the am i oh we're dead here it's not us i'm just let you
know that it's not us look at us look at us we had people
playing mysterious support it was the ghost guy it was our
spider-man look at our spider-man dude look oh they switched
to invis I paved the way to witness what happen look no they
didn't get a lot of they did they did i created space
i should have gone tanks no you did a lot too i did a lot
yeah you did a lot it was look at our the ghost guy he was
literally playing mystery heroes he didn't know what the
fuck to do oh yeah yeah holy Shit, 77k damage blocked.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Huge.
Yeah.
I was literally the all-fattery.
Okay.
Look.
Next game.
This game for- I think our warm-up's done.
Doobie, I'm pretty sure.
I think I'm so warmed up now.
Let me turn off my Donkey Kong music.
We just got- Chad, you gotta believe.
The two birds and dragons.
You got belief.
Send in your belief.
Put your hands in the air.
Give us your energy.
I'm gonna focus.
I gotta lock in.
Guys.
Put your hands up.
Give us your energy.
Oh my god.
The double Invis block.
I might have to play a bunch of Sharia again or a tank.
Let's see what Mikey plays.
You know what Mikey?
I'll flex for you.
anymore Mikey you and I have to play tank well I can play
tank if you want a DPS no it's okay it's okay oh you played
more tank than DPS now I should I don't know it's either
it's equal unless you want to play tank you want to swap it
I hate playing take it that's all right I'll play day okay
okay i just think i was doing like insane plays on dino so i
know it's not me yeah it's not i think so either
oh i was doing some crazy i grabbed that strange like 80
times remember we even got a pick on him early on and i
think we definitely should have got the point after I think
it's awesome.
I think it's awesome.
They were so scared.
They were scared of my dino.
They knew.
They were threatened by me.
They saw how much I was carrying the team.
All right, Mikey wants to play Thor.
I think three play.
You should play mag with the orb.
No, it's cool.
I'll play mag.
I can only punish her pretty much.
Why are you just fine, I think?
Okay.
They have to cage me.
You're too scared.
They don't like your elo.
People don't ban support, so there's no triple support or
something, or there's like unavoidable kind of.
It's unavoidable.
There's too many supports to ban fully ban triple.
Because like in triple, in the high reload, it's like, they
always have to ban Gambit.
If you have a Gambit player, you ban Loki so you don't want
to Gambit Loki.
And then you have to ban Invis or Invis or Ultron because
Ultron's really good on triple support.
And Invis is like one of the best supports right now.
Yeah.
So it's like, so it's Invis, Loki, Ultron uh gambit are like
the main uh support bands and then you have to ban black cat
or daredevil um
but oh thank you yeah that's right i'm taking here that's
right I didn't remember to Oh, I didn't mean to do that I
didn't mean to do that I'm going down I'm going down too
That's right, shield Alright
Can't see anything Okay, I wanted to shield him By shielding
myself instead Uh oh, oh, backing out of little bit i don't
know what he wants to aim at
should i like punish her because i keep shooting the tanks
but there's like no use because they just get healed so i
should just shoot like the backline right well yeah you can
farm your alt on tanks though if you want to but
obviously by shooting the tanks you're letting them build
more support also if you can't and shoot the uh shoot them
squishies then you should try to okay but if the tanks are
low just try then just shoot them the final kills all right
look see you guys i'm locking in 32 look at that oh slash
slash look at that see you freaking sliced them in half I'm
the better man.
I'm...
I'm at mag prime.
Oh my god, she went Emma!
Look at that!
Tank pool guy.
Oh, they double support all this.
Nice.
There I am.
I fucked up there.
I bubbled him.
I'm not gonna use my ult.
There.
Oh, look at that.
I did my job.
I bubbled my cloak.
They also used...
Yeah, yeah.
So that three of us is good.
Their Punisher is gonna alt now.
Yeah, I have alt for that.
I just gotta remember how to look at both my counters.
Don't get pissed, though.
Oh, you're okay.
You're gonna go.
Right here.
Get out.
Oh, shit!
I sacrificed myself for the greater good!
I tried to help you.
instead of my bubbling myself.
It's okay.
There we go.
I did it for the greater good.
The trade was worth it.
See, shouldn't have caged my dino.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you know they're tilted though.
on Scarlet Witch.
Yeah.
You know they're fucking tilted.
And she died.
Yeah.
Oh, they got rid of Double Tink.
Yay!
Let's go!
Oh my god, your A is to me!
Woohoo!
Come on, as them.
And welcome to the gem.
Which side you're on?
You'll need a top notch to win this one.
See?
It's not us.
I am him.
You're him!
You're literally him!
I punished them so hard.
Punisher gift?
That's some 56 shades shit.
Why was I thinking about that?
How else are you punishing them?
I'm...
I'm judge, jury, executioner!
I saw this, uh, Twitter.
I guess it's like some...
he streams like shirtless and plays Punisher okay like a guy
and they have they can like control their titties like
individually you know why yeah and he goes he like controls
one side and he's like judge jury execution that's good
that's good content there there's like a Punisher streamer
Line Punisher shotgun only like he literally got the one
above all just playing shotgun only never using any other
gun it's crazy yeah it's actually i know that's right guys
it was a clip on my twitter feed okay but that means it's on
here for you is it not that's because i like all the marvel
rivals like mods the mods of naked Punisher Oh shit.
Oh, okay.
Locking in.
I'm locking in now.
I got grabbed.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Oh, I accidentally pressed F.
I wasted my cooldown.
But don't worry.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I couldn't shield myself.
He got me too.
Where's our other?
Oh my god, you!
Okay, here we go.
I'm going over.
We're all taking so much damage!
Okay.
Alright, guy needs heal though.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
Okay.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
That's fine.
There you go.
She's one.
All right.
I can't get up there.
Kill him!
All right, that's fine.
They can't change for you.
We did it!
Yay!
It's just one fight.
Yippee!
Oh my god, you got A's!
See?
So easy.
Maybe I got MVP.
Oh my god.
See, warm-up done.
It's all uphill.
It's all downhill now.
I just need to play GPS.
It's gotta be on GPS.
Look at us.
Just one more game to rank up.
Yeah, just one more, guys.
One more.
Not even hard.
Look at that.
See?
I knew the wormhole was over.
What are you talking about?
You shot them down.
I saw it.
Yeah, you were kind of bad though.
No, we were really good.
We were really, really good and they were sort of bad.
But we are really, really good.
I see the vision, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, I'm the only Diamond player.
Oh, wait, no, I have another diamond player with me.
Uh, let's see.
I think you want to play.
I will be, I'll flex.
See what they want to play.
I think yeah, you and I might be tanking or oh, all right
Let's see.
Oh, this is a defense, huh?
Is this defense?
Oh, it is You want to play Groot or I can get Groot?
Oh, Groot's gonna be oh they batten die.
I know Let's see Yeah, flexing means I'm always gonna be on
tank duty.
That's true Yeah, usually fantastic see they're scared they
knew what i could do they're like oh no it's it's it's not
jokie bird and choo-choo i heard she's gonna pull up the the
dono you know in um in my elo yeah there's always like four
other support mains and then in my game like every other
game there's so many support these just so many yeah these
just in general support players yeah they think maybe they
did on purpose like you have to run triple support because
there's so many support players i think soon i mean it
started because people just kept running into support
players oh yeah i think that's why and i think support is
just such an overpowered role because the characters itself
are so like strong the right heroes could make all the yeah
oh do you know there's a voice changer in this game i don't
know there was one until recently Is that new, or has that
always been a thing?
And they talked about it in, like, the dev updates.
You know those videos that they put out?
They advertised it through that.
Oh.
It actually sounds pretty good.
Like, accurate.
There's one with aliens.
It's like, me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me.
Let's see.
I feel like if we're...
I have to play Mag, though, for the Anchor.
Okay.
Or, okay.
Should I play Groot?
I mean, Tank Pull and Groot both work.
All right, how's your Groot, though?
It's okay.
I think you you're probably better than me I'll just I'll do
I think this is good.
Yeah, I think this is good Mag is always like the anchor
tank.
I like how people are like Flex like play people who have
Lord on Magneto are they don't have it like consensually.
It's not for you They're not by choice.
They're just forced to play him because nobody else will
play.
Yeah And it's just it's not a choice if you have a lord on
mag i only realized recently that you can turn on like the
allied health bar oh yeah i'm like what the hell you're like
i don't know how i can see i don't know what their hp is how
am i supposed to know huh no they went i'm going in the back
all right oh my god i give you a bubble too Okay, where is
we have all we don't have we don't have in this Bad I
probably don't need to strange the point right now do it
right?
Um, I already left okay Took too long to figure it out.
It's bad only cuz like we don't have
Trying to shoot the squishies right now
I'm trying to help our Where is Oh my god, I know!
That's me too!
Oh my god, fuck this.
I'm just gonna shoot the squishies.
Fuck this.
I don't care anymore.
Oh my god, she's so low.
Alright, it's like this.
Alright, I somehow, I forced the Lunal because I walked into
her.
It works.
That's true.
Oh shit, this is bad.
Oh fuck, it cracked!
I mistimed it.
That's my bad.
I hailed it too long.
Oh my god!
Get this!
Get her away from me!
Where's our DPS, huh?
Where is our...
Do we not...
Is Invis bad?
Invis is not even bad!
Please!
Play Invis!
She is the strongest support in all of Rivals.
She's not even bad.
You know what you can do?
You just push her.
Just push her.
I don't think you keep watching.
Just fucking a pusher.
Oh,
I'm gonna chase my crosshair.
Bro, I'm just gonna die.
Fuck this.
Fuck this, I'm gonna go Emma.
I don't care.
I'm gonna grab.
Why?
I think I'm gonna switch.
I'm not.
Why did you all wait three people died okay i think that's
the worst part when you're not on support and you're like oh
my god i wish i was i'm gonna switch i think maybe i'll play
thing is that good for angela she's all right she's it's
just you won't get grabbed that's the thing about it i'm
fucking i'm i swear i'm gonna go on point that's the thing
Not all club players, but maybe all club players.
All right.
Oh my god.
I thought I had more heals, but I didn't.
Do we need to go triple support or something?
Maybe we're not getting a heal.
I think we're not getting enough heals.
Do you want to go to heal?
Oh, he's asking him.
play DPS you you you want to play yeah DPS you can go tank
okay not all cloak players but maybe all cloak players it's
not you it's because we're not on Invis it's because we're
not on Invis I mean I think well this guy was is tank now
okay yeah maybe it was him yeah maybe it's him You're right.
You're right.
It's him.
It's him and the lack of invis Angela is like F tier right
now by the way That's the thing Angela is So she should not
be getting away with any of this I saw those tier lists.
I saw all the pros putting Angela on F
I think in lower elo though people don't know that you could
just kill her Bam!
Get out of here!
Careful though, you're not in the support alt.
You're not in the support alt.
I'm trying.
I tried.
I tried my best to body block.
I didn't know where she went.
I got like some use out of it, I guess.
I got it fast.
Yeah, really fast.
Maybe it's because I had all on my...
thing kind of i don't remember this guy is lord oh wait
maybe he's like us you know like he's lord i'm mad because
he has the flex yeah i don't think he has he got that
oh my god i couldn't i got it
oh my god we went in this that's crazy
i'm trying my best
what the fuck how did she you can block my grab there's no
way all right all right that's no all right i
didn't want to kick him to the team so i could block it all
right it's fine
Why is he still there?
He's bad.
We killed him.
We didn't kill him!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
All right.
That's fine.
I'm coming back.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
Okay, we got to kill.
Oh, nice question mark, question mark, my old, huh?
That's...
It's not us, just remember!
Fucking finally.
Where did she fly to?
Trying to fucking ping her so that it's easier to keep
track.
I know there is...
Oh my god, okay, that was a good...
That's good.
Space created.
It's okay.
As soon as I switched, we were able to hold the point.
Exactly.
It's not us.
You got distracted by her ult.
Did our Phoenix ult at all?
I didn't even see her ult.
I don't even know, honestly.
She would ult the Luna ult that already ulted.
She has a moving Lord?
What's it called?
What's that?
There's a special name.
The moving Lord icon in Invis.
Yeah.
Maybe she's bored of playing Invis.
Angela comes out like once every 80 games.
This is the one time we knew it at Invis.
Oh yeah, yeah.
You mentioned there's Angela.
Yeah, all you have to do is just push.
Like, that's why Angela, like, that's why Angela's, like,
F-tier.
Because, like, she's so easy to counter.
All you have to do is just push her.
You push her, and then she loses, like, all her abilities.
Momentum.
And momentum, yeah.
I'll be sure to remember that.
I know if I...
I'll try my best.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
I think watch me play Punisher might be painful for some
people.
No, look at that!
You gotta kill!
Literally gotta kill!
Oh my god, they went Venom.
Reloading!
Alright, I got Luno.
I blocked that area.
We got it.
Easy.
Oh, are they my portal?
JK?
They couldn't get it?
No time.
Look at that.
Easy.
I'm finishing them.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
That's fucking right!
Hello.
Okay.
Wait, where is my- Okay, I was gonna say where is- I feel
like I've been 1 HP for a while.
way too long I was fine but thank you even the venom was on
them I didn't turn around I mean that's fine
oh oh my god the random random bullshit time all right
that's fine oh I almost kicked them out too I'm sad I got my
alt Where the fuck are people?
Yeah, there's no, yeah, yeah, you don't need to ult.
Just like how she doesn't need to ult there.
And just...
Yeah, yeah, who's...
No, yeah, that's just a strange.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'll push the card a little bit.
I'm setting up here.
Wait, can I set up here?
Oh, you can.
What the fuck?
Where did he go?
He went out of my hand.
I was like, he was in my hand.
Where did he go?
I tried to save him, but I couldn't do it.
Wait, where is it?
It's Strange, Strange, Strange!
Up behind us!
Oh.
There we go.
There we go
Okay, I'm doing stuff.
I was fine.
I'm punishing.
Yeah, punish him All right, I have my ult too.
Oh nice All right, we just keep punishing just keep
punishing It should be fine to help this too.
Where is going on?
I can't see anything.
I got him!
What is going on?
Well, I might be dead.
I might be dead.
No, I almost hit the med kit too!
It was fantastic!
Since when?
Oh, they literally just swapped it.
wait i have an idea
wait there's that string he's looking for all
go she's so fucking yay look at that so easy so look at that
choo-choo aboard the punisher tree so lame i got like both
their supports like i gotta go with something labor you just
seen that both i Literally just WK'd both your supports and
he kept running away from me.
I was like, stop!
Let me kill you!
What the fuck?
Look at the chat!
Classic Marvel Rivals chat.
Oh, Marvel.
I show women!
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I raked up.
Yes!
See, I told you.
I told you.
It was warm up.
It was all warm up.
Do we go again?
Of course.
What do you mean?
Of course we go again.
We could going again and again.
My god.
It's like you.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
crazy they're just so salty they're so salty I did not I was
you should have seen my screen when I played Emma Strange I
was just all over the place I would be scared of a big tall
woman too like running at you trying to grab your throat I
guess some people would not be scared of that's true kind of
like a turn on their side Oh, it's oh It's time for my
favorite favorite part lexing Wait, okay, there's no way you
want a DPS?
No, it's cool.
I can't play Punisher because this guy.
Oh, that's true That's true I can play Phoenix I think It's
your choice.
What do you want to do?
Oh, I try out my new hella skin.
Oh, you should yeah You just got it.
You should try out your new hella skin it's like it's true
you would the velocity of the bullets like me throwing it
that's true there's less clothes wait yeah there's less
clothes weighing you down 100 i agree all
right see what they bag is this oh this is defense yeah or
we have a penny so i could just i go mag or uh oh well i
guess you're not playing Groot or Dino.
Oh, all right.
I guess I'll go Mag.
All right, Emma with...
Actually, I'll go Mag.
You're going to get Lord Mag.
I know.
I'm going to get Lord Mag just from Filling.
This skin is insane.
I know.
I wish Rivals had more cool skins, you know?
Oh, yeah.
And more than just...
I like the Goon skins.
Don't get me right.
But sometimes, you know, sometimes you just want variety.
You know, you want to use your imagination on what's
underneath.
True!
You want to use your imagination.
Born to die, no force to mad.
I do like that the recent skins, skins, they seem like a
little more simple.
Yeah, that's true, yeah.
Some of the previous skins, there's like so much going on.
I'm like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, what?
Oh my god, this guy also has your skin for Punisher.
Look at him.
He's literally you.
That's literally me.
That's literally you.
You actually have another- It's all my last game.
Yeah, yeah, he got inspired by your last game.
Smacking.
I think he's very motivated now.
Oh, they have a Spider-Man, a Spooner Man.
What's that Spooner Man gonna do, huh?
Grab me?
as if oh they have a wolf okay he's gonna grab me actually
if anybody's gonna grab me it might be
that was good against spider though what
the fuck our gambit guy spider man oh i know i can't I
didn't know anything about it though.
I don't have any shields anymore.
Oh no, our Punisher is so dead.
It's okay!
It's not looking very pretty here too!
I went the wrong way, I don't know how the ring works!
Oh my god.
I'm still...
I think I might have to play Bucky instead.
Hello.
I slipped so long on point.
I just...
I'm counting on you, friends.
All right.
We might not be great.
Oh, wait.
You can play Flanders Chanel.
Oh, okay.
I'll switch after.
Okay.
But I got you.
Look at that.
It's protected.
Don't worry.
You're heroes here.
Oh.
Poor guy.
You was going to grab me, actually.
Nope, he sucked me up too.
Oh my god!
Oh please!
I think I can play bucket.
Just gotta change my...
Your crosshair?
Yeah.
I literally got like shot at by eight.
This is why.
Tank is a thankless role.
Yeah.
It is.
Oh, I'll wait, I guess.
I'll wait.
Goodbye, Neymar.
Let me watch him die.
Oh, unless...
Oh, he lives.
Alright, I'll wait for everybody.
Oh, careful.
They have a Wolverine.
Can you do that on purpose, or was that an accident?
Yeah, he did on purpose.
He did.
Holy shit, alright, guys.
Calm down.
Where is he?
I couldn't find her.
I literally couldn't find her.
Oh my god, I almost got him
Oh huge I'm so sad I couldn't go be him Okay, I can't, I
gotta switch I'm not good enough I believe I believe It's
not us though Um, yeah It's not us If I know anything, I
just know that we're doing our best.
This is our first time streaming.
Right, right.
You know how hard it is as a first time to stream and play?
You know?
It is.
There's a lot to handle.
There's a lot to double.
Yeah, exactly.
So like, it's not our fault.
We're just trying our best.
Oh, shit.
She definitely has all.
There you go.
Oh, I'm trying so hard, but then I also have to bubble
myself.
And then also I have to bubble here.
Faking is pain.
Oh, my God.
Man, I feel like Moon Knight would be good, but I don't
really play.
Like, he's easy to play, right?
Yeah, he's very easy, I believe.
Oh, he's banned.
Oh, wait, did we ban Moon Knight?
I don't remember.
Whoops.
Oh, here they are now.
You cannot be.
Judge, jury, executioner.
Jesus.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Check this here.
But it's not us.
They just have food.
Look.
It's okay.
It's not us.
They just have.
I deserve my catch 17 kills.
What the hell?
It's because he's getting assists.
He's getting assists.
You know?
I was like, they have more kills than their DPS.
He's getting assists from the other DPS.
That's basically it.
All right, let's see.
Oh, you want...
I can try Bucky, but I don't think it's...
We could do...
Let's see.
let's see i'm thinking i'm thinking all right okay they want
to go emma okay they go emma i can go strange okay actually
are we still okay i feel confident now i think this one will
go better yeah yeah this one this will work 30 seconds
before you attack get ready yoke on strange yep everything
will be fine oh we could actually a portal portal here oh no
they have spider-man they're gonna cancel it
yeah it's fine oh chat sorry I'm lagging right now it'll be
back all
right oh
my that mag was so low oh I'm solo too I'm solo as well all
right that is a lot of damage all right if they if they're
on spider-man I feel like I do have to I have to play mag to
bubble you guys I am not the man I used to be I have found a
Don't worry, it's fine.
We're going to reverse sweep this.
If there's a Spider-Man on you, let me know.
Okay, he's back here by the wheels.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'll shoot the squids.
I'll do my job.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I get burned so fast.
Okay, I'm searching again.
I don't know.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh.
Ah!
Never surrender!
Oh my god, all right.
Let's burn her.
Just burn her.
I killed Spider-Man by X-Man.
That's good!
That's a good ult, that's a good ult, that's a good ult.
I'm just slowly walking up.
Oh my god, all right.
I literally saved that man's life, so someone please.
Oh my god, excuse me?
All right, it's fine.
He went bubble mode.
The moment I used my...
And so I was like, excuse me.
Oh, and then he went and sucked me.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
There we go.
Woohoo!
There's winnable.
Yeah, I just think maybe we just need a little bit more
damage.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
More damage.
Oh, fuck.
That's awkward.
I got grappled.
Oh, no.
I got grabbed.
I didn't think he would do it.
It's alright.
Killing me means nothing.
Because I was so up close.
Oh, never mind.
I have fun issues, God.
What's that?
All right, let me bubble myself real quick.
I need to remember because this is not a Zarya bubble, I can
shoot a bubble for that.
I'm so conditioned to like, you know, not shoot bubbles when
you see it.
Because obviously it's bad.
That's all right.
Just take everything, I guess.
Oh my god, I feel like I feel like look around so much.
I have to be like, where is everything?
Oh, where is everything?
That's a good look.
What is going on?
Someone save our Emma.
There you go.
Save our Emma.
all right
wait somebody's on our car oh no it was rogue okay that's
good that's okay that's my dog too my dog knows whenever i'm
like streaming he barks yeah because he knows it's like oh
if i bark while she's streaming she'll have to pay attention
to me oh my god they like okay I'm like so fucking confused
are Luna Oh
My oh, my oh my power cannot be I think I switch again here
Whoa, whoa, I hear Nice killed the scooter man All right
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying my hardest to shoot them for her.
There we go.
We shot him.
All right.
Got it.
I am frozen.
Oh no.
I don't think he realized that they're going to portal?
Look at our punish it.
Oh.
That's fine.
Fuck.
Fucking Spider-Man.
There you go.
I'm trying to kill this Neymar!
There we go.
He's one.
Alright.
We're still in this.
We got him.
We're still we're still here.
We got that pretty quick kind of yep We're still here.
Well, much better.
I learned my mistakes from getting grabbed last time
Uh-oh All right
Where's my guy?
I'm trying to...
Where is he?
Where's my guy?
I'm sorry!
I tried so hard!
I need to protect him!
Holy shit!
Okay, they used everything, though.
We don't have anything, but they also used everything.
That's fine.
I don't know if I just played.
I think maybe hella?
No, dude.
I'll play worse than I for sure.
I believe in the hella.
I believe.
What could go wrong?
It's too late, it's too.
It's possible.
Oh my god, I have to...
I'll use bubble.
I was so low.
I got you.
I got you a bubble.
Go again.
You okay.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
You went as many as possible.
Fuck.
It's okay.
I'm here.
This white box is so low.
I know.
It's okay.
I'm here.
Okay.
We got that.
I got two.
No!
I must kill them too!
Is that...
It's the Spooner pad!
Okay, alright, there we go.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
No pressure.
That was pretty easy.
Nothing to worry about.
We have so much time.
It's okay.
We're doing it.
There's nothing to worry about.
I might restart my stream.
Maybe it's a server thing.
Oh, it's true.
It's true.
It's ping.
She's, she literally has like, you know, like, um, in Dragon
Ball's E, like the, the Piccolo shit.
I think, yeah, she's getting weighed down.
Her internet's weighing her down right now.
Guys.
Her pot.
Round three.
safe haven for all mutants i'm frozen though that has
nothing to do with my yeah she has weighted clothing the way
to close or bring her down 30 seconds before you attack get
ready we're back what does cracoa have to say about all
right um this guy switched off furniture to store i guess
i'll say bucky we have to figure it out on our own yeah wait
we're her internet's weighted to keep it fair guys Wanted to
make it fair.
Well, I'm not liking in-game.
That's good.
It's just the stream.
You guys can't see my epic gameplay.
I'm like, I'm killing it.
Yeah, she killed- Oh my god.
You guys missed out.
She just killed 20 people.
You just missed out, guys.
Oh my god.
Trying to take as much damage as possible so I can.
Well, not that much damage.
Not that much damage.
Shot!
Oh my god, you're crazy.
I'm missing.
I'm like so scared.
I'm trying to get the cloak, but I'm missing.
Okay, well I got her.
Alright.
Guys, I got the cloak.
Nice!
I'm trying to get as much farm for our supports.
So you can get it all.
God, my crosshair might be a bit too tiny.
For tank.
Because everything's going on.
It's like too tiny to see sometimes.
Alright.
That's good.
I wish she walked up more.
Oh, that's bad.
Never mind.
It's no longer good I got grabbed.
Oh, no
I was a distraction.
It was a zoning ult.
Exactly.
Oh fuck there were too many.
Yeah, I can't touch it now.
You gotta touch it down.
No
Alright, we got it pretty far.
It's not bad.
Yeah, we got it pretty far.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I think I might play Squirrel Girl here.
I think Squirrel Girl is a good idea.
I might play...
Hmm.
I'll still play Maddie.
You sure you don't want a DPS?
Yeah, yeah, give me.
Wait, really?
We're going to play?
I'll go hello.
Let's go.
Yeah, or I'm going to whiff a lot of shots, maybe.
Maybe.
No.
I might need to increase my cross here.
I think I want to notice, because I'm whiffing on tank
shots, is that when you're up front, there's just, I can't
see my cross here.
I literally can't see it.
The small ones, right?
There's so much stuff going on.
much stuff.
Yeah, there's so much stuff going on.
I don't know where my crosshair is anymore.
I was just like, where is it?
There's our penny setup.
There's so much stuff happening on the screen, guys.
Do you notice that, dragons?
I just feel like it's just so many things on my screen.
I don't even know where I'm shooting at.
I haven't.
Okay, I haven't aimed in a while.
out of those so this is gonna be interesting I don't want to
farm too much all support all three people though trying
to say I can I'll go work on peeling if I have to all right
all right okay they're peeling as long as spider-man I hear
him it's over he's in front he's front line his front line
now yeah
he's trying to build as much oil as oh oh i'm just trying to
build oh it's for when they push up yeah
oh i'm lucky oh oh you might have to swap this actually yeah
they're gonna hard push here you might be strange yeah oh
shit it's okay you're on strange though where the fuck can
you portal here just portal on point on to point
all right oh
my god I'm shaking too much with my aim what oh my where was
he he jumped up I was gonna use my health there oh that's
unlucky I'm coming back now I was like wondering where he
came from I'm just gonna save my ult for last fight my I
need to stop that vehicle in its tracks.
Can I go back to Meg?
Yeah.
I feel so slow.
I'm like shaking too much with my aim right now.
Oh!
My supports were still not here.
I kept backing up and everything.
We shouldn't have switched them in game, sorry.
I had to like warm up.
I also got three.
i'm going back now we can still have one more fight but it
has to be like not a full team
oh my god no none of us kidding we have to die i can't i
can't if i want to we just get getting staggered but it's
not us though it wasn't us though yeah hey we just didn't
back up fully i just I tried to go back as far as I can.
Who is?
Oh, it's this guy.
Okay.
It's alright.
It's okay.
This is just... And then we're going to win after that.
Don't worry.
And then we're going to start winning again.
Okay, true.
True, true.
It was just one bad game.
We were doing a lot.
That was a long game.
That was a long game, yeah.
That was.
I'm going to put my cross here higher.
him i'm playing tank holy i could not see shit i cannot see
anything oh oh hold on i'm gonna i'll be right back i gotta
get a cord really quick all right all right no problem
all right i'm putting this bigger so i can at least see my
crosshair that's crazy i literally couldn't see anything i
was like am i hitting am i hitting i don't hear the shots
why am i not Pop, pop!
Where are the shots going?
It was a little rough.
It was a little...
I just feel...
I don't know.
It's just a tank thing.
I feel like it's a...
It's a tank thing.
Because, like, you're all up in your face.
But then there's so many things going on as well.
You're showing things going on as well.
It's so hard.
Alright, this is a lot better.
The circle is a lot better.
There you go.
I think there's just so many things going.
I'm not used to it.
When I'm support, it's like...
Things are a lot calmer.
It feels a lot calmer when you're support.
When you're a tank, you see like 20 things on your screen.
I'm like, what is all of this?
I'm so overwhelmed.
to turn around I'd be like what was that I feel like I'm
schizo as hell and I'm on tank I was like did you hear that
who who's that spider-man like oh the voices what you are
the voices I was telling them how like playing tank feels
like I'm schizophrenic because I'm always I'm gonna be like
What was that?
I had to turn around all the time and be like, where are
they?
It's scary because if you turn around too much, like, you
just die.
Yeah, you're not tanking because you're just letting your
stuff get hit.
All right, I'm ready.
Okay.
Here we go.
All right.
I'm back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
back we're so back this is where we turn it all around right
here right now I've seen people they're like how do you get
into games with so many other support mains I never have
anybody that wants to play support on my team we're not
getting into games like that either look at that wait wait
oh okay take a break from tank okay yay Now I get to be on
vacation.
You know what?
Now I'll ban that.
The other team should be scared.
Yeah, they should be scared.
I'm like the third DPS.
Okay.
I always say people who are like tank players, they're like
masochists.
I don't know how they wake up, play tank, and then nothing
else.
It has to be just because nobody else will play tank.
There's people who play it, like, willingly.
Like, it's their choice.
Yeah, they're sick in the head.
Yeah, yeah.
Please seek help.
You're only making it worse.
But I'm thankful for them.
But we appreciate you.
We appreciate you, Tank Players.
Even if you...
Were you going to ban that thing?
I was one that banned the last thing, so...
Oh, I'll ban group.
Okay.
I didn't realize I was the only one doing vans.
Yeah, usually I just ignore it.
My team gets it.
I was like, you're right.
I'm depressed and I'm also a tank player.
Oh my god.
I should probably play like Magneto here, right?
With Venom, yeah.
You need an anchor tank.
Because Venom's a dive.
That's why like, that's why like Mag is like always like the
the pick yeah like sense oh wait Gambit is open god damn
okay I'll do that yay alright it's Gambit time I don't know
if that's enough heals though White Fox Gambit we'll see
yeah I take the damage so I can feel something join stream
gets called sick in the head sad you know you know how What
you can do to change this?
No, no, you know what to do?
You can change this.
Not be a tank main.
There's still a...
Oh, we need them!
No, there's still...
There's still a chance to redeem yourself.
Get out before it's too late.
There's still a chance.
Believe in the triple DPS triple support call.
Yeah, who needs tanks anyway?
We can still fix you.
There is hope for all of you.
no they're just we're just they're just flipping for it
that's fine because i am whoa what the
fuck okay like i don't know what what did we flip to all
right my way okay maybe not oh we do have to run gambit
though because they're on gambit we have no supports okay
you can still survive though but no supports should i i'm
gonna portal uh i don't know we have time but shoot yeah all
right i can't wait it says oh oh okay i think i could have
had it yeah okay then you could try
okay and they flipped it i was not expecting to flip All
right, all right, all right, all right, Lord.
Here you go.
I need the heal.
Oh, no, our poor star lord.
I'm just gonna...
What the fuck?
There's like...
Okay, our white fox is not white foxing.
No, our white foxing.
Fox was anti-dive, but she's not anti-diving.
I'm like, that's your whole job, White Fox.
You gotta anti-dive.
You have one job.
Could have played Groot.
She was, like, not on melee, too.
I was, like, confused.
That's fine.
I have all here, I'm gonna use it.
Yeah, we got him though, that's fine.
There you go.
I saved her.
I got a kill!
Yeah!
Oh, nice.
I got killed too!
All right, they have their gambit all- wait, wait, we used
our fucking- when do we use our white fox?
Okay, we're a bit fucked because they do have gambit all.
I didn't even realize we used our white fox all up.
is this true i heard that if the gambit dies it is all
everybody loses their all if they have it and we just have
to explode the gambit but it's a little hard because
everyone else would also be trying to kill us yeah but yes
this strange yeah i was gonna say i don't have i'm just
gonna back out a little bit because I know they have a
gambit up.
Also, I know they have this too.
Oh, that's bad.
I was...
Frick.
I had to reload.
I didn't have blood.
Maybe I did.
I just had to reload.
It was just unfortunate.
What should I use my ult for, like, like, me?
Oh, where are you going?
Yeah, you can...
Use it on...
aggressively, too.
I mean, one's still up.
I mean...
Oh,
I wish I had.
Alright.
They also technically have, like, three support ults because
they have Captain America.
I already got pooped up in the air.
That's fine.
I was slammed, Doug.
It's okay.
I saw you got five.
It was five in my heart.
I saw it.
See, they're all dead.
It's because of your all.
Exactly.
Whoa!
Oh!
Why?
Oh, I got cocky.
I thought I could kill her.
She double-head shot me, I think.
Oh, no, she used her right-click on me.
Our white fox uses it.
I mean, my dog's buggy, sorry.
Oh, they're opening portal.
Our white fox is using her all too aggressively.
She just needs to use it defensively.
I mean...
Holy Jesus.
shit how did she take oh no i didn't have a dash
come on it there are strange that oh we don't have a strange
wait we could tp i'm on it i believe i can't keep you right
here tp you got this i'm right for you
Okay.
Come on, too.
Oh, no!
Come back!
I got kills!
I got the Invis!
What is this exit?
Fuck!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's still winnable!
Go, go, go, go!
Just keep hitting!
You got this!
Oh my god, please, please.
Oh, Arluna!
Oh, our Punisher is dead, dead.
What the fuck?
Oh, I can't do anything.
I can.
Okay, that's...
Arluna's pretty good.
That's a good foothold.
Alright.
It's a little, a little scary.
No.
Oh, our Dara.
What the fuck?
I'm so good.
There you go.
I got her.
Oh, nice.
What?
Oh, my God.
I didn't, how much did she hit me for?
Oh, I didn't even realize I was that low.
That was my bad.
They're here.
It's okay.
We have...
Oh, never mind.
Oh, we might need a...
Oh, our black panther.
Oh, it's okay.
Now we have two main... we have a main healer now.
There we go.
Oh, that's bad for me.
What?
No!
The damage boost!
Ah!
Their bucky is good.
Kind of, I guess.
I guess.
40 kills, what the fuck?
Okay, yeah, never mind.
It's just a Bucky diff.
Wait, we can still do this.
We can still do this.
It is winnable.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
but oh oh they want to heal all right yes or are you gonna
switch or all right you're doing so good though i know but
he's our venom toes might not be doing so well oh he's not
even a tvs player i can bike if you oh yeah that's you I'll
try to...
Okay.
Do I have to play Magneto again?
No, he's on Mag.
Oh.
Are you guys on Mag?
I switched.
Okay.
Bro.
It's not even...
Bro, he has champion and he chose DPS.
Well, maybe they thought that their skills would transfer
over, you know?
Maybe.
That's true.
What were they playing?
Like, Starlord?
I don't know.
They were on Starlord, yeah.
They weren't.
I played Starlord in a long, hot minute.
They are on champion Luna.
And we were last picked.
I remembered.
What is there, fucking?
There you go.
God's change.
He's so low.
How did our Luna die?
Um...
There we go.
I got...
Yeah, I...
Oh, I killed two!
I got a good kill on there, fucking Scylok, too!
I fucking Scylok dived!
That's fucking right, run.
You're strange.
I'm so scared.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
I'm in their backline.
I'll wait until you guys are pushing in.
Fuck.
I fucked it up.
Oh, I fucked up my dash because it's been so long.
Alright, I'm gonna let this guy solo tank.
Oh.
More damage?
Wait, we can get it.
Wait, not this guy.
This guy is, like, actually throwing, though.
Like, the strange.
Guys.
Oh, shit.
King of Toes.
Oh, Kings of Ten?
What the fuck is that name?
Alright.
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-
Okay, that was not intentional, bro.
Wait, who's so...
alive oh it's captain america i got him
good luck yeah yeah he fucked up because he used portal
already so i know he didn't have portal oh my god really i'm
gonna heal this here nice no i almost killed him There you
go.
I can ult this, but they're just gonna...
I'm gonna bait alt out here.
And we can get...
Nice.
Oh shit, wait you guys...
Wait, I didn't realize you guys got healed, but it's fine.
They use sidelock ult.
I use sidelock ult.
When do you think I should ult?
Um...
I can ult now.
Just bait out a support ult.
Yeah, see?
Just bait it out.
Oh, that's huge.
We got to save our mag, though.
That's a good bait.
Oh, where is he?
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh, there's my dog.
That was my dog's turn to bark.
Oh, don't worry.
He'll get closer.
closer.
He's one.
Oh my god, the silo's one too.
Oh my god, I shook too much there.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, he's got closer.
He got closer.
Dad, stop.
Stop.
I can't focus.
No.
All
right, I'm coming over.
I almost got her too.
That's good.
There you go.
He's one?
Got him?
Who's that?
You're big footsteps, huh?
Yeah, this is the big footsteps coming from.
So loud, he wasn't even that close.
pretty loud his big feet what the fuck why is our in the
onesie skin where you see his big old feet you know the skin
where it's like his toes are oh his toes are red
uh i got the i baited it out oh we don't have any support oh
man it's fine we got one of the
I don't I missed my slash this guy's AFK I think they lost
one I'm sad I missed the slash no if they were it would be
please okay there you go
there she oh nice
Like, oh, locked in.
He has all, the thing has all, by the way.
Oh, okay.
He might use it here, honestly.
I'm just gonna...
Actually, no, he can't use it here.
Because we won the fight.
I'm just gonna try and farm.
He's so low!
Fuck!
I farmed a lot of ult though off of him.
so that's good like fire maturity on my up off of this guy
oh please if we can kill him we win I have to reload there
we go we got it gonna push oh no I have all for the fight
they push up up.
Okay.
I don't know how to do this.
Me and my mag.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
The mag and maybe me and my mag might have over killed it
there.
Oh, no, it's good.
It's good.
We got it.
start my all and we both just fucked up their supports oh
all right that's how you win the fight right that's how we
win the fight that's true they're strange i think they're
strangers like it's special is there he's good right like
like that like yeah in fact i was like in our fucking front
line yeah so strange all right all right oh yeah oh i
haven't played i haven't played sidelock in so long i'm just
like okay to be fair chat i feel like you know their
sidelock is a champion sidelock and i'm you know i'm i'm
sort of like you know little.
You know?
He's having a hard time.
Maybe, um, can say I give him a little?
I'm gonna say that and then he's gonna fucking kill me.
I think you're doing great.
Do they swap siloed or do you swap skins?
Oh, I have to back up.
I almost killed him, but she dashed away she got what the
fuck what is he doing here oh my god okay he like went
invisible with where I wanted to go oh that Luna was low oh
nice we got the Luna yeah he is
Oh, he couldn't get it.
Nice.
He didn't get it.
Okay, winnable.
Winnable.
Either winnable or winnable, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It's our tie or winnable.
Yeah.
Okay.
We get the winnable.
Look at that.
Just remember when on attack he had 40 kills?
That's Scytheok?
Look at him.
We blocked him.
Oh, my God.
It's crazy how many kills.
Yeah.
It's all right.
We got this.
I think.
Is it okay if we go triple DPS here?
Because it worked the last time.
I mean, it worked.
You can, yeah.
You want to try.
Yeah.
All right.
We blocked their Bucky and Silo from getting more kills.
That's good.
All we had to do was put Venom toes on Luna.
That's all we had to do.
We side-blocked them.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Hi.
All right, I'm on the left side.
We could portal, but...
I don't think it's worth it.
Yeah, I think we should save it.
They're probably gonna play Penny.
Didn't they play Penny or am I...
I mean, we could portal.
You can try.
Portal onto point, like exactly on point.
Well, then what if we waste it?
Okay.
That's the Gamba.
I'll wait, I'll wait.
Oh, they tried a portal.
They fucked up their portal.
Good.
No way you didn't die!
Okay.
I'm fine here.
Oh!
Oh no!
Okay, I'm forward-linked.
I got him this!
Oh nice!
Alright, nice.
here we go
champion champion siloed change your main bro change your
main little bro oh they had somebody that left no no he
wasn't no it was a 6v6 oh really?
yeah yeah okay yeah oh and then he left later I didn't even
right he left during the end of uh uh i don't remember i it
wasn't like full 5v6 though uh there is afk it looked oh
apparently it was lagging oh that's lagging yeah that's
right guys you can't see it guys look i was 1v i literally
lead 1v3 guys all that siloed was a 1v1 carried us that game
when you where you were playing tank no i was playing i was
playing gambit and then men of toes was like was like can i
play support and i was just like all right let me pull out
the siloed i haven't touched siloed in a very long time
maybe since the last time we collab marvel rivals because i
remember you played her oh yeah yeah yeah i think so too oh
a mouse since he was way too though of course let's keep
going we go again are we higher than where we started i'm
higher where we started i think we're even we're even all
right and then we win this and we're higher than where we
started yeah oh it's this Is this map?
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Hello chat.
Oh, I think the action issues are okay right now.
It seems better now.
Aw, thank you for watching the stream.
I know it's like during collab, it's kind of hard to talk to
the chat.
Like I want to say something, but I don't want to, I don't
know.
I feel like I'm going to talk over my collab.
partner if i talk to the chat too much or something you know
but thanks guys i saw there's like a prime and a sub just
hanging out it's okay this is uh i well i usually don't play
like these types of characters but i know it's probably more
interesting than watching me play like cloak and dagger or
something like that i like playing Punisher he's fun
Yeah, it seems like there was an issue earlier with the lag
and then as soon as I restarted the stream, it was better.
Which I can't do that when I stream on YouTube because then
I messes it up.
I'm back!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
What should we play?
I'll just build, honestly.
Okay.
I'll say, I'll gambit.
They banned him.
We banned him.
Oh, wait.
All right.
Homel, homel's man, what do you play?
Like a tank.
Oh?
All right.
Yeah.
Me on support now.
Let's see.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I guess I will cloak.
Bad.
Oh wait, Invis is not bad.
Alright, Invis time.
Don't worry, you'll never die.
I'll keep you up.
You play Invis, your Elo too, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I play all the supports except for...
Uh...
Except for Jeff.
No, Ultra and I like Ultra.
And Jeff and White White Fox.
White Fox is so hard to play and hire Elo.
Yeah, it seems like it'd be hard to be with her.
Yeah, cause like, she's, you know, you gotta know when to do
the melee stuff too because if you don't do at the correct
time you fucking explode oh yeah
so quiet where's the other team where are they oh they're
just around the corner yeah at least they give us space
that's good give us a lot of space yeah give us a lot of
space
There's more space than I Holy shit Luna Why are you
frontlining?
I don't know why she went up there Yeah, I was like, Luna
What are you doing?
Pushing them away for you Oh I'm gonna try and keep you up
Just because if I die I'm about to die Yeah I'll lose my ult
Try and keep you up as much as I can I'll push them away I
have ult soon No I built all so fast too.
Oh, they built all that as well.
Oh, I can use this aggressively.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought we would kill somebody.
That was a good aggressive look.
Oh, we did kill someone.
Yeah.
We got it.
Oh, they got res.
Oh, it's okay.
That means they can't get res again.
I'm just gonna push them away.
Um, so...
Oh, goodbye, Luna!
Goodbye!
Why is there cloak up here?
What the hell?
Oh, she cloak-alted.
I do want to know why her hello is up there too.
Oh, she was ulting!
Uh...
I'm gonna ult soon.
I guess I should use it more defensively to pull him up.
I was in the public.
I don't understand.
Oh wait, nice.
We win those.
It's okay, I believe.
I believe.
I heard those ding, ding, dings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the game was lagging.
So you missed the dinks, chat.
Yeah.
It happened.
Like the frames exactly where the dinks were that they just
didn't go through.
Yep.
It was like a sound delay, you know?
Don't you hate it when that happens?
Those goddamn sound delays.
Jesus.
Wait, there's like squizz.
Oh.
Yeah.
Not bad.
Is it worth fighting this?
I feel like I'm just gonna save.
I feel like we kite it.
We can just kite it.
There
we go.
Oh shit.
Oh.
How did he...
Whoa.
Oh that's on me!
Oh I'm okay.
I saved you.
Yay!
My hero!
What the fuck?
Why is this mag still alive?
There you go.
I try to block the heals for that mag.
Yeah.
All right, save it or...
Our Luna is like as frontline as me right now.
Thank you.
All right.
You're still healthy?
I don't know about our strangers also so healthy?
There's a bunch of stuff going on.
There is a lot going on, honestly.
Like, I don't know what's going on anymore.
We're winning!
That's yet, exactly.
Exactly.
That's what's going on.
We're winning.
I'm
just trying to make sure our train fucking lives.
I can save it.
I'll wait a little bit.
Ours last longer.
Ours should last longer.
Oh shit, I fucked up.
Our Punisher is so fucked.
uh a well out as me um they're oh wait oh i can't kill
anything that's unfortunate i'm backing up for us we've got
to back up fully like how do we not kill this
um i pulled someone back nice nice we can push up with that
Nice.
I'm gonna push up, push up, push up.
There we go.
See?
Everything's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
Yay!
Look at that.
There we go.
Easy.
I have a...
I'm gonna use it aggressively.
Actually, I'll use it with my Punisher, actually.
Anyone willing to help?
That's much better.
Punisher does really well with Milo.
Oh yeah, yeah, with the Invis Hall.
Yeah, he just comes right in.
He's got the naked Punisher skin.
Yeah, yeah.
To control the recoil.
You know, it's the recoil control.
Oh.
My shield didn't go off.
It's alright.
There it is.
I did the wrong alt.
It's okay, it's okay.
You're sending a message.
Yeah, yeah.
Luna has alt, so I hope she does.
Oh, she doesn't.
Alt Luna!
What?
Like, why did we not lose?
Yes!
Why didn't we?
Wait, Luna!
Oh, wait!
No, I was on it.
I was literally on it.
That's crazy.
I was literally on it, too.
Man.
I don't even know what our Luna was doing.
She was saving it for...
Honestly, I think she was saving it for Marvel Rivals, too.
Doobie.
I mean, she used it, right?
Or did she...
She used it when...
She used it when three people died.
So it was just us.
So it was us three.
Her loot.
What tank do you think is good here?
Um...
I think Groot didn't make me who I am today.
My family did.
I think...
I mean, yeah, Groot is always good.
Hey.
Yeah, I'll try to keep you up.
You're going to be like a little old battery.
Are you going to make me grow like a big tree?
We're going to cut you down and then we'll start from the
beginning.
Because baby Groot's cute.
That's cute.
We got to sell the merch.
It's all about the merch, baby.
The capitalism, fuck yeah.
Are you interested in the baby Yoda?
What is his name?
Oh my god, Grogu?
I think he's a little...
I think he should have been baby Yoda.
Is he not?
His official name is Baby.
They're like, we're not, it's not baby Yoda, it's Grogu.
Oh.
They should have committed.
They should have literally called him baby Yoda.
Oh.
Oh, where the fuck is the magic?
I heard survive this.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, she's dead.
Everybody's taking so much...
Take down my wall, babe.
Oh!
Everyone's taking so much damage.
I do have a... but...
I can try to keep you up with my luck.
I have my alt I could use it
I don't know if that was a good idea baby I'm not a good
group I just saw our Luna got slammed okay I know for sure
it's not us our Luna is very questionable Aren't you?
I won't disappear so easily.
Still a chance to stop them.
Are Luna is very questionable.
Here comes the merc with a mouth.
Man.
Oh my god.
Luna, why?
You're not gonna...
Luna, get out of here!
Yeah, you took her.
I picked last.
Can't be me.
No, I forgot you can't.
I didn't think about that.
Man, I wish I had another.
There we go.
I'm keeping you up right now.
Not him though.
Not him.
Is that a punishment?
I thought he punished you.
Alright.
That's unlucky.
I jumped in there to help, but I just killed myself.
Yeah.
We weren't.
There was not enough stacks.
Do you think if we go triple support, I could...
Oh.
We could try.
Is White Fox's main or is she like?
She's an off healer.
It's White Fox, Ultron, Mantis.
Which, uh, Ultron, White Fox, Mantis.
Uh, okay.
I'll try and let you guys...
Alright, I'm gonna pull it back a little bit and I'll use it
when you're a little...
and kite a little bit.
I'll use it just to save her.
It's fine.
We don't need to use anything else.
Nope!
They don't know the plan.
They didn't know the plan.
To be fair, it's not on them.
They didn't realize the plan was to not use anything else.
I think we just needed more healing.
Maybe, is the Luna maybe not healing?
I think, no, the Luna is just She's definitely struggling.
Yeah.
The Luna's just not, the Luna's just bad.
That's all I'll say.
She's just not a great player.
Maybe she's tired.
That's true.
This is, maybe this is her first game.
Yeah, this is her one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's her warm-up game.
I could not shield that.
No matter how much I would have won it too
Oh, Luna, I hope Okay, I do not Oh, oh, Luna Luna Just
another Luna day Honestly It's okay, we have white fox on
though Yeah, just tell If you want to tell me when Uh Trust
your heart.
Trust your heart unless I start yelling at you at all.
Okay.
All right.
Trust your heart.
Trust it.
Oh my god.
No!
I couldn't get my shield out in time.
It's okay.
Our Luna's healing.
I'm actually seeing our Luna healing.
I'm so happy for it.
I won't disappear so easily.
Oh my god, I didn't even know that guy was low.
Wait, they're running solo support.
Wait, it's possible.
Wait, they're portaling, they're portaling.
Wait, they only have one rocket?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where did she come from?
Wait, we're holding it.
We're good?
Are we good?
Maybe?
I'm coming back now?
Okay, we lost the support.
No, we're not good.
TP to one of them, just TP to one of them.
Reload.
I have all I have all here.
Let me try it.
We got it.
Nice.
I'm going to keep our I'm going to keep our Punisher alive.
I'm going to keep him alive.
There you go.
Nothing to worry about.
Not even close.
Two, two, one.
No wheels.
Maybe it's for their team, right?
Yeah, yeah, we're there.
I was gonna say it.
This fucker cannot say that.
It is...
I kept that fucker alive the entire time.
And he did do a lot, though.
Classic.
GG, no heals.
I think matches still I place.
I think I need like...
40k plus healing.
No heals.
I need to...
Want to do two more games to finish placements?
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, now we're up one.
Okay, yeah, we are.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I do have twerky mode!
Oh, fuck.
Out of everything?
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot for some reason in the It happened with a new
update.
You can't twerk too long on venom or it stops.
Oh What the heck?
I don't know.
It's like too much gooning or something.
I think so Yeah, it just stops.
I don't even touch anything.
I put twerk on and then my revival is just say stop Oh, is
it in the title screen?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It does that for all emotes.
I don't know why.
Yeah They stopped it.
I would cute.
Yep, I'm ready.
They're too scared.
Yeah, I don't know why they wouldn't make it just, like,
endless for...
I know.
Because I tried to use the sitting emote.
Oh, no, I think the sitting emote was endless, but then the
other ones are not.
Yeah, because, like, well, the dancing ones are endless,
too.
I think it's like...
But they used to be endless on the main menu, and then they
stopped.
Mm-hmm.
You're too...
You wouldn't let us go in anymore.
You could do Dino here if you want.
I'm gonna have to.
They picked it.
Alright.
Might be time to bring back Dino.
Uh, I'm ban group.
Maybe.
Oh, no, no.
Okay.
We're gonna Dino.
They'll probably ban it, though, on the other team.
That's true.
Uh-uh.
We can do this.
I believe.
Do I never notice where your eyes kind of remind me of like
3D glasses?
Oh, true.
What was your first 3D movie?
Maybe for- Maybe it was like a Spy Kids movie.
Wait, no, mine is the Love, with Shark Boy and Lava Girl.
That was my very first 3D movie.
I've always wanted to do, you know, the Shark Boy song, the
dream, dream, dream.
Are you new cover?
I wanted to cover that song.
Dream, dream, dream, dream, dream, dream.
Is it even long enough to be like...
I think it covers a cover.
True.
It can always just be like a short.
Yeah, that's true.
Dream, dream, dream, dream, dream.
It's like two minutes long.
Oh, wait, no, actually.
Dream shark boy.
Shark boy.
However, girl, how long is that song?
Oh, it's like...
It's like 40 seconds.
Oh, okay.
That's like, that's good.
Yeah.
Oh, do you want a tank or do you want a DPS?
Um, no, well, I'll tank.
You got...
You can relax now.
Okay.
I'll go, Emma.
We'll switch.
Maybe next game is we have to do this again.
then you dps yeah yeah yeah well i need one two games so
yeah so next game i'll dps okay let's go see we always go
back up oh they went penny i see like i i can see where the
mines are i'm gonna put my shield up
Fucked up my thing.
Oh,
I missed the...
Whoa!
Let me grab the mines real quick.
So much damage.
Wait, I'm gonna wait a little bit.
Ah!
Shoot.
Okay.
Yeah, I got...
I got the punishers.
Oh, we got two.
I'm gonna grab them.
I got it.
Oh, I'm helping.
You're helping.
All right.
Whoops.
Oh, yours is.
Are we having a party?
Yeah, we're part- right partying oh wait she lives all right
it's fine yeah doing a little part oh he's so low
what the is going on though
stuff is going on oh nice that's fine um i don't think we
need that though No, I've caught, yeah, I really, we're,
we're one little, we're, um, all right, we're, all right,
Luna, you know, she's flexing, she's flexing, yeah, yeah,
yeah, that's true, that's true, she just wanted to flex on
us here, oh, no, I'm gonna have to back up a little,
I don't know why.
Oh, backing up, backing up.
Oh, I should use my smoke.
I don't know why I did it.
My brain.
It's okay.
That taken.
It's a huge up.
Huge up.
Oh, huge up.
I'm gonna ult two.
You!
I'm just kidding.
I will.
Where you go?
I see you.
I don't see you.
But I don't see her.
You're so lucky.
I was just about to kill him.
This game is easy.
I didn't even, I'm not even doing anything.
See, it's so easy.
I know, right?
Those other games we had, we were just...
The other games we lost, we were just trying to...
Oh my god, you might be dead.
I tried to shield you.
I really did try to shield you.
It was maybe...
Maybe too hard.
I read chat and they were like...
There was like one person.
There was like one guy.
Oh!
you got one guy you got one oh shit okay we all get one guy
sometimes we got the mask no no no we're carrying we're
creating space yeah exactly yeah yeah we're that look at
that beautiful shield placement I did to create space what
the fuck oh whoa whoa I hope what the fuck what that's on me
I may have created too much space We're so good.
Okay, I will.
I'll use my...
Not now, though.
That's okay.
Oh.
Alright.
I'll do it here.
That's right!
Space creating!
Space has been created.
Easiest.
Where you go?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, wait.
I need heals.
I'm ulting!
She's ulting!
Gosh, she is.
Wait, oh, okay.
I'm shooting.
Oh, I thought that was me.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, they actually bubbled it.
I'm trying so hard to kill their raccoon right now.
Oh my god, wait, we're...
Alright, we're out reset.
Only 60 seconds left.
I can't even...
I can't grab him!
They're too far!
Oh!
I'll pretend I didn't see that.
Oh, our Bucky ult...
Our Bucky ulted...
Might have ulted a shielding, double shielded mag.
It was a little bit embarrassing.
Maybe.
Okay.
Where is everything?
Alright, there we go.
Alright, we got this.
We got this.
That's fine.
Good.
We have, we even grabbed them with time too.
Look at what?
We got lots of time in the bank.
Oh, yeah.
Look at that.
It's so winnable.
I believe.
Oh, that's true.
Penny is good.
Penny and your Elo, right?
You said it before?
Um, not really.
Because you just shoot the mines.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
We got this.
Yep.
So winnable.
I'm ready to grab.
I bet they're not even gonna be able to get first point.
Exactly, we're gonna full hold this.
Like, look at us.
Look at us.
Yeah, I'm right here.
We're so good.
Look at me.
Those are so good.
We're so hot, we're just like winners, you know?
I know.
If we lose, it's just because I want us to lose.
It's for the content.
Yeah, it's just where we wanted.
If we win too much, it won't be as fun to watch, you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Get out of here!
That's right.
My point!
Get that furry out of my game.
The Captain America.
Oh, and Rocket, yeah.
And Rocket, yeah.
That's right.
Get him out of here.
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
We are furries dead.
No!
Penny!
Penny's a furry?
Yeah, technically.
It's a spider.
Spiders count.
Yeah, I guess spiders do have fur, huh?
Oh, that's true.
I wasn't even thinking that.
I'm just trying to...
someone kill the stream oh my god
yeah I got yeah she's in the first suit her the penny is the
first yeah the mech is a first suit yeah if you think about
it wait I can all this watch the way I'm gonna break her the
strange shield and i'll up it
it works i think i got healed i think i might all
where is she wait we win this with that do we oh my god i'm
dead That's okay, we still win these.
Ah.
Okay, we might have used every ult.
That might be a little oopsies.
That's okay, maybe...
Mine was really big impact, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw it.
Mine too.
They have...
This was actually.
They do have...
No, they have strange ult, so...
Only 60 seconds left.
Oh What if my shield was there?
I had the diamond shield I thought I blocked this I'm gonna
play squirrel go And random bullshit.
Let's go Oh Can't kill them even though I feel like I'm
doing damage I think it's just targeting the wrong people.
I think maybe You guys got focused by maybe?
Well, I'm trying to help the backline with Captain America.
And they still just die even though I'm shotgunning him.
Alright, nice.
That was a good one too.
Where did it go?
I fucked up.
I actually dropped down.
That was my bad.
Wait, is that con so blue?
I actually fell down.
Also, I like the...
Yeah.
I fell into their backlight accidentally.
That was a little oopsie.
Just a little oopsie.
There's still a chance to stop them.
I think the solution to our problem is more furry too.
That's true.
I broke it, but...
Oh.
I was just trying to stall on point.
I don't have enough.
I'm trying to...
Oh, I don't want Waste Up, though, but it's just me.
Oh, we're portaling?
Okay, no!
I thought my support was fully healing me.
That was my bad.
I...
I thought my support and we were on the same page.
I was like, you'll keep me up, I'll keep you up.
I feel like we're going to be able to hold this.
Yeah, yeah.
I think so, too.
I believe.
Wait, that Szilard's one.
God damn it.
Oh, nice.
I knew he was one.
He's full, I said.
One drop down.
Oh, my God.
He jumped over me the moment I wanted to grab him.
Oh, there's full pushing this though I got rocket all
right they did free push this a lot which is a little scary
that's okay just a little scary all
right I don't I don't have any shields here.
Oh my god, that is a lot.
Maybe I shouldn't have played.
Oh, that was a lot of damage.
I'm trying to just stay alive.
Oh, he's so low.
I know.
I don't want to waste my ult here I think we can come oh no
wait are we here I should I didn't know if I should have
ults is there I thought we could touch we can we can all
right I'm coming out I got one
The pressure's low, the pressure's low!
Oh, nice.
Okay, 30 seconds.
All right.
I got Dulled off.
Oh, they're gonna portal.
We don't have support ults.
They might have starlord ults here, though.
You might have to save your ult when everybody's there.
Okay, yeah.
When they all start landing in.
Not yet, not yet.
I'm going to have to use it here.
That's huge.
Nice.
Yeah!
That's a good old.
That was a good old.
Oh my god.
This guy got 72.
Holy shit.
What the?
Oh my god.
He was doing generational plays.
It's the power of furries.
The power of furries.
Yeah.
I'm going to cry.
He's just like I had 41.
Oh my god.
Look at this final hit, Stoomy.
Oh, damn.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Valid reaction.
Very valid.
It's very valid.
Nice.
All right, go next.
All right, LG.
Next game is LG.
What's that?
Oh, last game.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
LG, LG.
I hope that Bucky isn't on the enemy team.
Yeah, he had his name hidden, I think.
Oh, yeah.
Do you think you want to be?
I don't know.
It would be a shame if he farms us.
Wait.
Well, did he have Lord Bucky?
I don't remember.
I don't remember, honestly.
I don't think so.
was doing bucky things i did i did fuck him over um oh yeah
my turn oh you might have oh my turn oh we have a dono too i
can mag i think maybe minasong konichiwa all right here we
go yeah
all right only bad punisher no team up like I wasn't gonna
play anyways yeah we don't care
bye whatever yeah you're just gonna make us play our actual
characters
I think wait what do you Are you gonna play Scyloc again?
I might play Scyloc, yeah.
That'd be good on this control point.
That's true.
Wait, oh, it is domination.
I could do Moon Knight too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's random bullshit, Tad.
I'm really bad on Moon Knight, but I can do Moon.
We'll see how it goes.
If it doesn't work, I'll go Scyloc.
Alright, I'm ready to lock in.
I'm ready.
last game we got to get a win yeah I'm ready don't worry
don't worry if they start winning I'll I'll I'll send
something over onto their PayPal so what do you mean um
nothing you know we're doing a good job with the mail yeah
something in the mail you know yeah legal reasons that's a
joke or legal reason that's a joke that's a joke we don't
know their addresses not yet
This is the same bucky.
Is it?
How are you sure?
They have default skin.
Yeah, but all the buckies have default skins though.
It is the best one.
That's true.
It is.
And the one where he's shirtless.
Oh, that one's okay.
But it's a Christmas skin, so it's like...
It's not the same.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Yeah, he has to be shirtless all year round.
Why only Christmas, you know?
Yeah.
Wait, I think they also are Moon Knight.
They might be a better Moon Knight than me.
Yeah, they do.
They have the hot Moon Knight again.
Oh.
Holy shit, how is he still alive?
Okay, I was gonna say.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to send it over here.
Oh no!
Oh no.
I like you.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's like a, it's like a Moonlight versus
Moonlight right now.
Oh.
Oh shit, wait, there is a Namor up top.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, the map changed for us.
Oh, I got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
I can push me off!
So yeah, we pushed them off too!
Did he?
Oh, okay.
I thought he just jumped off.
We pushed him off as well.
Okay, I also have...
I also have random bullshit ready.
Oh my god, it is the Bucky!
It is him!
Don't worry, we got this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yeah!
What's going on?
It's so easy.
I'm just throwing random shit out.
us okay this might this is not easy this is not easy we're
not jinxing it this might not be easy
oh my god here's so many hits right now
oh shit wait how did everybody's die how did everyone die
was this like he's freaking hacking he shoots so fast i
think that's just yeah i think he's just spamming he might
have the new Give me a mouse.
Good job.
All right.
Wee.
Oh, hi.
It's okay.
I have my ult.
Bucky has his ult.
It's five.
We're so healthy.
I have ult.
I'm gonna use it here.
I'm gonna quick it up though.
I'm sorry.
I separated them.
So they're not getting healed.
Nice, okay.
There we go, we got the tanks.
Yep, we got the tanks.
Look at that.
Oh my god, all right.
Looking, what's wrong with you?
See, look at that.
Oh, there's someone.
The Luka Tuna's won.
No!
Coming back!
Oh, no, no, no.
The other DPS is...
Oh, fuck, okay.
I'm almost here.
Is Alina has an alt hit, or?
Oh, and the only issue is...
Oh, my God.
I got grabbed.
I literally just got back.
Or I might have to swap.
I might have to play a natural character now.
Oh, my God.
uh try and kill the name yeah
and they're not trash
oh my god i've been like i i've been playing i play too much
moon night i played too much moon night i couldn't i played
too much moon night i'm switching that's okay i'm gonna
portal anyway No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, did you use it?
Oh, yes, okay.
But did you already use it?
Yep.
Okay.
I was waiting to use my ult, but the Luna, their Luna, I
didn't see her ult.
Maybe I wasn't there.
Oh my god.
I played too much Moon Knight.
I was just like, I was just like, how do I aim again?
And too much, I was just chucking my shin, gender direction.
I forgot to correct my aim.
and yet so strange all right i mean yeah just needed that
warm-up yeah yeah just needed a warm-up i'm good now
everything's fine now 30 seconds before you attack get ready
sorry see the bucky does have 40 kills so we're all
contributing equally they still whisper the name of common
one alive all right all right ball folks you know the story
all right i vote too oh we both have votes What is it?
Easy.
So easy.
I will say there is a lot of supports in this rank.
I feel like we're always like our DPS or tank.
Oh.
Wait, what?
We're always like DPS or tank.
There's like so many.
That happens in games when I play.
Don't always.
He's like, where is she?
She...
Okay.
I'll wait for the... Oh, never mind.
Oh, I wanted to wait until...
I'll use Mellot later then.
That's fine.
Oh wait.
Like damage is so low on Magneto.
I don't know how people get like a...
Are you okay?
Oh my god, I need heals here.
Oh, I didn't realize everyone's gonna die to that.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god, he is Moon Knight now!
Oh, he's Moon Knight.
Uh...
I guess I have this too much for Bucky.
I guess so.
He's not able to do much.
I also think we are not...
Maybe just no space for him.
Yeah, my bad.
I could switch the place somebody else.
Maybe Emma?
Stupid.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, we used double support up.
Yeah, Emma would be good only because I just realized
they're running Dino too.
So you should play Emma.
I don't care about my own.
I'm speaking now.
Alright.
Quick go.
Wait, what?
past it there were so many bubbles that couldn't tell where
which one was our ours okay all right this one you want one
swap had a good tank all right yeah i can swap okay i can't
make space it's okay it's okay is punisher man oh yeah
didn't they man yeah they did like i'm not gonna play
punisher anyways whatever my all that is sharp my mind is
sharper okay go mantis and damage boost you and we could we
could run triple support yeah
all right here we go yes yes i'm very impressed can we focus
on the battle and not on chewing the scenery i got to dance
oh Guy, yay!
See, look, our Bucky can't carry us.
Look at him.
The moment he got off Bucky, he's had this.
One trick.
Yeah, he's a one trick.
He's a fucking one trick, guys.
Or don't.
I really don't care.
Where's our 50 kills?
Bucky, where is it?
70, yeah.
Yeah, where is it, huh?
That's trucking, right?
Where is it?
We had our 50 kills.
Everything would have been fine.
Where'd they go?
They just, like, collapsed right now.
Yeah.
Oh, it's because we had our...
Our ults.
Our Moon Knight.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Holy shit!
Oh, my God!
We collapsed!
Yeah.
He just let us burn ours up, I guess.
Oh my god.
How did we collapse?
Luna ult.
I was not expecting a double collapse there.
Oh, crap.
I got him.
I know this.
He's so lucky I had to reload.
there you go there we go I got him all right we have all
right we have Matt assault first would you match us all
aggressively okay I'll tell you I'll let you know when yeah
but our supports are probably also gonna try to well I guess
yeah well if it's aggressively yeah yeah yeah just tell me
just all right right There
you go.
Violent.
I have no idea.
Oh!
Hello, thank you.
Okay.
That's good.
The double Donald lizard.
Alright.
There we go.
Where's that moon knight?
Oh, you got this.
off in the corner.
No, no, I'm back down.
Oh, I almost killed him.
Trying to trick me.
It was a trap.
Oh my god, Dono!
Dono!
I got him.
She's coming back.
He's coming back, though.
Careful.
Oh my god.
He really wants to...
Oh my god!
Alright, we didn't have any.
It's okay.
We didn't have any ults anyway.
It's good.
They're using ults.
They used to, though, and we have nothing.
Oh, the Neymar's coming closer.
I can...
I blocked it.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I need it.
Oh no!
I've been waiting for yous!
I should have backed...
I should not peeked at all.
We have one more reset.
I have ult too.
Okay.
Back up.
I can ult this.
I think it's just our dana.
It's just absorbing too much heals.
I just want to save him.
I don't want to get staggered.
It's huge.
I'm dead.
I'm dead in a minute!
Oh no.
I hit strange.
We have to let our Luna grab it.
grab healers.
No!
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Nice.
We did it.
It's not even hard.
So easy.
See you guys?
Wasn't even hard.
So easy.
Yeah, didn't sweat at all.
Nope.
Easiest game of my life.
look at that look at us oh finish yeah diamond one let's go
okay i'll place diamond one yeah yeah you got ranked higher
than me wow surprises a higher elo in general look at that
dude look at us go see you're you're higher you were higher
rank than what you started i'm diamond one look at us see we
can climb guys We can climb tank slash DPS Stokey can climb
I'm not I'm not I think you only played support like in one
or two games I think it was like it was one and a half
because we swap roles remember oh I swapped roles with venom
toes.
So it was one and a half Oh, yeah, I remember their name.
I remember his name.
Of course that is his name was so memorable Yeah, we win
Honestly.
Easy W.
Easy.
GG.
So easy.
Wasn't whiffing my shots or anything.
Yeah, same.
Yep, same.
Same.
Didn't whiff my ult.
Never died with ult.
Always winning.
Look at us go.
Or got an upvote.
I received some updutes too from our teammates.
Epic updutes.
Thank you teammates.
Yeah, thank you teammates.
I know.
I know we carried.
oops they were good though yeah they were good i didn't
forget our dino was good our dino our dino took all my heels
too all right i literally was like i was like chill get
healed i'm standing next to our dino i think our dino
literally absorbed every heel possible yeah i don't know
what that was when you died there maybe wait they didn't
have a dino did they no they did they did but i think you
might have been in his shield i think i might have been in
his shield too i grabbed I grabbed the Dino, though.
I just think like...
I think I literally just exploded because everybody was
like, kill her!
She's got the Dino!
Kill her!
Yeah.
Huh?
Oh.
Sorry, I had an audio issue on my end.
It's okay.
Oh, it did.
All right.
Oh, someone said, as an eternity tank player, you did root.
Thank you.
Thank, I know.
I think, in fact, I think I'm like a one above all tank
there.
Honestly.
I could see it.
Yeah, and I could see Duby also being a one above all tank
as well.
Oh, yeah, I don't know.
I don't know about that.
A one above all tank slash DPS right there, guys.
I'll take it.
Let's go.
Hey, we went positive, though, Duby.
We went positive.
So in the end, so in the end, technically, we are sort of
like one above all players.
Ah.
If you think about it.
Yeah.
Yeah, we would stretch it.
Like, when we stretch it, then sure.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Thanks, Joby, for joining me in rank.
I had so much fun.
Yeah, thanks for the free boost.
It wasn't a boost.
It was not a boost, guys.
You see me struggle.
I was kidding.
That was a joke for legal purposes.
For legal purposes, I wasn't boosting.
guys i was i was struggling so hard i was struggling so hard
and trying my hard out yeah well you didn't even play like
the stuff you usually play exactly exactly i was off rolling
i was off rolling everyone mm-hmm you know what no thank you
dubie for the free boost oh you're welcome yeah wait is that
allowed though um am i allowed to boost
I guess, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're allowed to, because
I have, I have, I got sponsored by Marvel Rivals before, so,
so legally, legally, yeah, yeah, yeah, but for Duby, Duby,
she won't get hit, you know?
True, they won't know.
Yeah, they won't know, she's not contractually obligated.
Yeah, I'm, I'm, I don't have to be brand safe.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, she's on Twitch, too, guys, she's on
Twitch, she's more free to do.
I can have nude mods.
Shoot, you can, technically.
I could.
Should I have?
No, I'm just kidding.
That was fun, though.
It's so much fun to me.
I'm glad we went positive.
I really, I'm really happy.
I didn't take you down to plat.
That's the win for me.
Well, we did.
We just dipped our toes in.
Yeah, we dipped our toes.
We just wanted to see what it was like down there, you know?
We just wanted to say hello to them and be like, Yeah, it
was awful, actually.
Yeah, I'm glad we're out of there.
I'm glad we're not in that pool, you know?
We're in the better, we're in the diamond pool.
I feel bad for Plot players, sorry.
They're in the Winnie Hut Junior.
We're in the Winnie Hut, and they're in the Winnie Hut
Junior.
Yeah, yeah, thank God we're in the Winnie Hut, too, baby.
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank you.
I know, our first collab ever.
Our first stream and first collab.
went really well we did pretty good first-time streamers
first-time rivalers yeah it's their first time here time
born yeah first time women first time women yeah first time
existence you know first time simulation you know we're just
feeding the ai to get better you're you're feeding the
algorithm okay first time chatters thank you first time
chatters oh my god oh yeah
time streamers yeah you know first time members i know hey
you know this is our first time playing marvel rivals too i
can't believe we got a diamond first time that's pretty good
yeah i know really good i think we could go pro duty as our
first time yeah our second time we'll go pro yeah on the
second time you'll see us up there you'll see us up there on
those esports screens that's
I don't know, that's fun though.
Thank you again, dude.
We should play again.
I know, like, you like, you're always, like, playing off
stream.
I would see you off stream playing.
You'd be like, yeah.
But this past week, yeah, a lot.
Yeah, I'd be like, oh, green Sonic is on.
Enviable Rams.
That's it.
I'm going invisible.
I'm invisible Sonic now.
Invisible Sonic.
See, that's why I'm always invisible, so that you won't
know.
no one would know it's also how I avoid where oh oh yeah you
lagged a little bit thank you oh it's me yeah I think so oh
okay yeah yeah it's your internet like is your internet okay
yeah yeah it's been I've been able to like play Marvel
Rivals but I haven't been able like it's been rubber banding
sometimes like in Rivals or just streaming not today because
I fixed it today but Oh, that's good.
That's good.
I'm glad you were able to fix it, because I know, like, it's
like the last time I saw you did, like, two waiting rooms
from it.
I was surprised you were able to run Deadlock with the last
time.
No, no, it was really bad when I played Deadlock.
It was, like, really bad.
It was unplayable.
Oh, my God.
I've wanted to learn Deadlock.
I've been, like, trying to hype myself up to learn it.
I really want to learn that game.
easy to learn i heard i heard that it's just the mobile part
i'm so oh my my tiny brain just wants to shoot things
instead of yeah learning items and stuff and i'm so oh i'm
so bad with it although you don't need to learn items really
you don't really you just follow the guide just by left to
right no you there's not even a guide you just get like
three times every round and there oh it's only it's one out
of three choices so Yeah, it's really simple.
So they're not even, it's a good way to learn the game, I
think.
Oh, I see, yeah, I know, like some of my friends are saying
to just try Streetball because that's like the easiest way
to learn.
It's like, what was it called?
It's like there's one, something similar to League where
the, the one lane thing is similar.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, Ram.
I just hate the MOBA part, man.
I just, it's the MOBA.
It's the same as like other shooters, though.
It's just overwatch has the thing.
I just hate farming.
Like why do I want to shoot the tiny guys when I can shoot
you?
Yeah Street brawl you don't have to shoot well you could
yeah there is still in street brawl you have to like shoot
some stuff Yeah, one day.
I know cuz like I know deadlock's gonna be really popular
too when it finally you know it's still in alpha Yeah, it's
still in alpha.
It's crazy.
I know I know for I know like the moment it's out of alpha
it's gonna like um it's gonna like go crazy because it's
already like really popular but it's also just i think
there's also some people who can't even play because maybe
they don't have like a friend that has deadlock or something
that's true yeah or like get invited yeah yeah but like if
at the moment anyone can get invited type it but you just
have to know someone to get invited um and also like they
might not have servers too in that region as well because
there's only like a selected Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, so like some countries might not have the servers to
play Deadlock.
Man, what's that?
Yeah.
Sikes.
I'm pretty sure for those who want to try out Deadlock, they
can just go on Twitter and be like, does anyone have a
Deadlock code?
Oh, yeah.
I read it probably too.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, does anyone have a Deadlock invite?
And they're like, whoa, there you go.
And they've got for anyone.
I gave you my Reddit gold if you invite me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll give you the updates.
If you, if I can have, I can have an invite.
And that's like one of the games I've been wanting to play
for a while.
It's just...
Oh, you ever need an extra person?
I'll play.
Oh, I'm down.
Yeah, you can teach me.
I want to learn Rem.
I want...
Oh, yeah, Rem's so fun.
And I like playing Rem too.
Yeah, I mean, he's just a little guy.
He doesn't sound like...
Ah!
He's just a little guy.
He's just an eepy little guy.
But then I have to learn...
yeah but then the worst part about deadlock is that you have
to learn like what like three to four characters because you
don't know what character you're gonna get right uh yeah
yeah pretty much yeah i mean i only know like two and i
always get like one of the two you really uh i hope i was
like watching one of my friends play and every time he
doesn't get his character so i'm like what if that happens
to me right yeah some of the characters i mean like if you
learn Not their abilities, but the items transfer over.
So, like, if it's a character that does spirit damage, it's
like, you pretty much do the same build.
Like, for example, I play Rim.
And then I also play Page.
And they kind of have the same build, too.
Oh, because they're both support, right?
Uh, yeah.
But in that game, like, kind of any character could be a
support build a little bit.
Oh, I see.
It just depends on...
If you get the right items, yeah.
Yeah, it just depends on the item itself.
Oh, I see.
I see.
myself up to play deadlock and then you could teach me and
then and then i'm gonna yell and i'm gonna cry no who yelled
at by who our teammates are they like what the is this rep
doing and i'm like it's my first day it's my first time
streaming deadlock yeah people in deadlock might be more
mean than people in marvel i feel like because it's moba you
know like moba players are one of the most toxic players out
there too yeah didn't they add voice chat to league of
legends they're planning to i think it's in the beta they
said it was like in the beta and the people were like why oh
yeah did you hear how overwatch has uh match vc now oh it
does yeah yeah it's like all chat yeah it has yeah as soon
as the game ends like you can go and do all like all chat
and then just You're so fucking bad.
I miss Counter-Strike used to have that, like, I think,
in-between rounds or, like, at the end of the game.
I feel like we're...
We took it out, though.
I think we're...
It's like we're bringing back bullying.
I think the games are like...
But it gets like, let's bring back bullying!
It's kind of nostalgic, though.
Yeah, yeah, it's like the Xbox.
Yeah.
Bring back the Xbox era.
I think it's crazy, though, when Marvel Rivals and people
start getting super heated, because it...
you it's recorded oh yeah that's true oh my god okay okay um
i told this to my my dragons about this one time but um so
there was one instance so like uh in marvel rivals there's
an algorithm where it can instant mute you if you say
certain words certain gamer words so yeah yeah so it was
there was a clip of this going on it was so funny where like
um there was like um i think it was like a black guy uh and
he met another black guy in marvel arrivals and he's like
wait are you black and he's like yeah i'm black oh my god
and then he said the gamer word to him like yo and he said
the game right and then the other guy was like no don't say
it no and then he got instant muted like oh and then like
right after that's crazy it works that fast yeah it was so
fast because then like people were like yo gamer word they
were like yo gave her word and then and then they're like
and the guy was like wait no we're not supposed to say it no
oh well psa i guess don't do that you guys should know that
anyway he tried to warn him yeah and then they and then they
both got yeah they both got instant muted right after it was
crazy i was like i'm sure there's a list out there of words
you can't say yeah i know like the algorithm goes crazy
sometimes too like i remembered like um because like you
can't type certain words as well yeah yeah so it's yeah i
know like overwatch has the similar sensor where it's like
if it's a bad word um though you can't they'll have like a
sensor being like oh uh reveal what they said they said
something bad but sometimes it's like really dumb i remember
one time the guy um he was like you're bad and then it
censored the message oh yeah it does yeah i forgot about
that and counter strike too you can just turn off the filter
yeah kind of nice yeah it's not really nice but you know
it's nice to have the option yeah nice to have the option
you know but yeah um but it's funny that they're bringing
slowly bringing it back with the whole You're like, bring
back the good old days.
The turn off the limiters.
Yeah, exactly.
It's definitely more controlled, though.
I mean, it's not the same, really.
It's not the out, because they're always listening.
Yeah.
I think maybe that's why.
So they'll be like, so it's easier, you know, those who
can't control themselves.
And then, you know, and then they'll, like, easier to ban.
Yeah.
Because they're given, yeah.
Because they're given the freedom to say, they want and
they're like oop there they go goodbye easy bands easy bands
have you ever played zombies uh like call of duty yeah um i
think like only once or twice like i mean not a lot i've
been wanting to play zombies are you down for some zombies
in the future i think it depends which game is it because
aren't there a few games there's like um i need a newest one
i know like apparently people are saying don't play the
older i don't know if it's fixed now um but uh there was one
time where i don't know if you heard about it but people
were like don't play cod zombies because all the servers got
hacked what yeah like how how i don't know but apparently
like so all the servers and cod zombies uh got hacked or
something and um people were like apparently like people
would like randomly jump into jump into your game or
something like the hackers and then we'll try to get your
data or some shit yeah they can enter your yeah they can get
your lobby oh man that sucks yeah but I don't know I think
the newest one is okay now it's okay because it's more on
the current servers but yeah I would I'd be down to try it
yeah I'm fucking down and I didn't try the newest zombies I
just know like all the Easter eggs and everything it's like
whole board mode right yeah yeah it's like uh it's basically
it's like left for dead but with but with easter eggs and
stuff all scattered around oh there's like a safe house you
have to move around like that there well not safe house but
you just gotta move around everywhere and grab upgrades and
stuff okay yeah anytime i'm so down i've been looking for
people for cod zombies because i've always wanted i think i
only played it like only played it once uh it's like four
players or it's more yeah it's four players yeah uh hi that
sounds like good time yeah it's always a good time but yeah
wow i had a good time doobie me too Mm-hmm.
Right.
Saying goodbye.
Man, thanks for joining me.
I really appreciate it.
I'm so looking forward.
Thank you for inviting me.
I'm so looking forward to our concert together.
Our concert.
Oh my God.
Your concert that I get to have a special party.
Okay, Doobie chose the song for us to sing.
It's so good.
Like, it was stuck in our heads.
for a while when yeah yeah when we're like practicing for it
we're like oh my god it was yeah if you guys are able to
catch it you're gonna freaking love it oh my god oh and the
court wait oh you didn't see the choreo yet oh i gotta send
you the choreo later i should probably yeah oh my i gotta
send you the choreo later it's it's crazy it's i forgot to
okay It's so fun.
It's so fun.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I hope you have a nice night.
You too.
I hope you have...
Thank you for playing.
Thank you to the doobers, the doobies, the doodus, the...
Not doodus.
The doobers.
The...
the Dumagachi, the...
Dubergachi, the...
What's the green guy called?
The...
Dupus?
Oh, why so much poop?
Mr. Doos?
Mr.
The Dumites?
The...
What else?
The doodles?
Oh, the doodles!
You already said that.
I said doodles, but not the doodles.
The doodles, really?
The doodles.
This is why I'll never pick a name.
This is why, but then if you pick a name, this wouldn't
happen.
But it's hard.
I gotta pick the perfect one, but there isn't anything yet.
It'll come to me.
Just wait.
It'll be so good.
be so good guys it's gonna be it's gonna be so worth oh my
god i see the lababas on your chat the lababas the the
doobers the this is just bullying this is me and matt chat
i'll be like hey doodos what you doing that's you just sound
like a Classic cliche bully.
Get in the lockers, la-doodos.
Come on.
Go in for a swirly la-doodos.
Do babies.
Isn't this like your summer outfit?
Yeah, it's my summer outfit.
Yeah, summer vacation started.
That what?
Oh my god, she's...
They're entering it.
Into the locker.
It's messed up.
yeah i'm like the night the 90s this is in the 90s and i'll
be like i slammed i slammed the locker beside you and like
hey do do's i got my lunch money ready they slap their super
chats out of their hand yeah they spill all over the floor
yeah yeah and they look up at me and it's like what you're
gonna cry little doos you guys gonna cry the doobies oh yeah
well dragons are they're They're gooning?
They're...
They...
Um...
Well, it's the shoe fence, I guess.
It's...
They know, though.
They know.
Those words don't hurt them.
But the nasty degenerates.
They know what they are.
You guys are the party kids or something.
The party kids.
They're gonna go.
cry do babies whatever i'm leaving i'm leaving i gotta
protect my chat i gotta protect their integrity smell you
later chat get behind me don't worry i'll fight her off
don't worry stay back don't worry chat i'll fight her with
with my with my lips or something yeah you know girls cuties
oh Oh, man, not the cooties.
Enemies to lovers.
Yeah, oh, that's my favorite trope, though.
That's a classic, though.
That is a good taste.
Good taste.
I do appreciate the good taste.
What a noble sacrifice that Doobie's doing for you guys.
Yeah, it's like that one meme where I'll just take a bunch
of, like, the shots, you know, for you guys, and I'll
protect you.
the one where he like cross like put his hands out like it's
a arms like a cross and stuff yeah yeah all right all right
i'll let you hang out with the duberts i'll hang out with my
dragoons thank you again doobie thank you and goodbye the
doodos my bad you too dragon their knuckles are
dragon did out that one was good though that one was good um
that was fun i had a great time i live great time hanging
out with dubie as always uh that was good that was a good
one you know she could also be a 90s the 90s bully with me
she'd be like like the dnd and 90s bullies Coming up to your
locker and be like, Where's our lunch money?
Anyway, thank you all for joining me today.
I had it, like I said, I had a great time playing with 2V.
And I hope we get to play more games.
I hope we get to play more games together.
Always love hanging out with her.
She's always, you know, she's, she's, what's the word?
oh my gosh sorry my brain is fried all i could think about
is the do do's and the do birds and doodles and doobies and
um she's all i'm trying to say she's like on fire in in
rivals what's the word that she's like killing in and rivals
oh my god she's skilled in the game there's a word for it uh
here's my lunch please will leave me some more mr broken
bond thank you listen for chat thank you thank you yes it
was it was a really yeah she's correct that's the word she's
cracked she's cracked and rivaled so it was really fun um
and maybe we can do zombies together next time i always want
i want to do a zombies collab with people so um but yeah hey
guys hey guys I'm gonna head off now.
Thank you all for coming as always.
I hope you guys enjoyed the fun games today.
Um, um, my very optimal tank play.
Uh, my very, I swear to God, like 70, 80% of that time when
I was on tank, I have no idea what was going on.
I will be very honest with you guys.
I, I, I was just hope, I was pressing buttons, hoping that I
hit something, uh, a very very optimal tank play i was just
like hope i hit something hope these shots land hope i am
creating space right now uh exactly i was making space guys
that's all that matters i was making space it truly is the
thankless job uh but yeah I'm gonna go head off now.
I gotta go walk.
Dad.
But thank y'all for coming.
Thank you all for hanging out with me.
Thank you to Julie for hanging out with me today.
I'm happy to... I heard that she was always playing off
stream and stuff and she always wanted people to play with.
That's why I asked her if she wants to play rank.
Because, you know, I always want people to play with too.
So, glad she was free.
And now we had a great time playing together.
Anyway, as always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you
stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody ball gosh or mine